you jinxed me
this is [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
tremendous that was my first Led
Zeppelin now that's the first one I ever
had that took me toward the tremendous
level and I will listen to houses of the
Holy
I would listen to dancing days and I was
so young that I was scared of no quarter
so I would skip over it and go to the
ocean you got to be a certain age listen
to no quarter you ain't ready for that
yeah I found about Led Zeppelin from
this girl that lived up a street for me
when I was 13 there was a girl that
lived up the street that [ __ ]
everybody she was 21 and I was 13 and
she pulled around me but I couldn't get
it up I was too young but she played
comfortably numb' the first time I ever
kissed a chick cuz the 21 year old chick
when I was 13 and she's grabbing my dick
but nothing was going on I was panicking
but that song comfortably numb' will
always be associated in my mind with a
girl and and and black dog that was the
first time I ever heard black dog was
his chick she turned me on his Epling
turn me out a lot of good music man
that's amazing when they take and you go
home and go what the [ __ ] was that
yes oh I had no idea because the only
music I had heard when I was 13 was
probably a new kiss I knew about kiss
was a kiss fan already but I didn't know
about that many bands it was hot you had
to listen to the radio you know you
didn't you couldn't like I didn't have
friends who like turned me onto too much
music it's like it was hard to find out
about good stuff so when I first found
out about Zep I'm like how the [ __ ] did
I not know about this so I got the call
early this morning at 8 in the morning
and Philadelphia freedom was I'm young
John and I started singing him my wife
is looking like when the [ __ ] did you
learn these lyrics I go dog oh this is
sixth grade on Fridays mr. Levite Oh
will let me go in front of the class at
one o'clock and I was saying
Philadelphia freedom my lip synced and
my eyes adored you by Frankie Valli's
[ __ ] let's take [ __ ] deep with
that with with [ __ ] the hell in John
people are rememb Elton John ha every
once in a while get caught up and Johnny
came along the house country comfort
come freak a funeral for a friend last
week something was on Daniel my friend
hmm and again there's two gay guys live
across the street from me but they're
the [ __ ] weirdest gay guys cuz they
don't go out don't do nothing they
sitting that [ __ ] house all day I
want to kick that door down and go you
know me tell you [ __ ] gay get out
there is free sperm is free you got up
Santa Monica you know that dick is free
free these two pigs I stay in the
[ __ ] and they're not gay together
what they're not together then other
roommates yeah they're roommates and
they never [ __ ] go out every once in
one the daytime they take a cruise there
in front of house feeding cats so one of
the other dad got out of the car was
listen to him John and I was blasting I
was stoned
you know when the weed and the music
just connect this one I pulled up to the
house and they were like out there and I
hope not the window I go nobody in this
country remembers when Elton John used
to swing dick like a [ __ ] and
they just looked at me looked at each
other whereas nobody in this car and
nobody gave a [ __ ] he was gay like you
had an idea him and Bernie Taupin
we're gay but you know he could be but
who gives a [ __ ] dog street fighting man
yeah all that [ __ ] was just brilliant
you know everything anybody that that
song it's a little bit funny you know
that [ __ ] everybody knows that [ __ ]
Jam you broke up to that you gave a girl
your first hickey you fingered somebody
for that there's always some Rocket Man
what's the one in know what's the movie
about the young kid who was the writer
and they all got a little tiny dancer
what is him and they all was singing it
on the [ __ ] bus and you were feeling
it you're like god damn how is that when
a band wasn't in that supposed to be who
that's supposed to be theoretically and
almost famous
wasn't that supposed to be Led Zeppelin
or somebody big time that they were
writing about when they were on the bus
I thought it was Morrison wasn't it
supposed to be no I don't think it was
the doors
although speaking last Friday night
[ __ ] The Doors live at the Hollywood
Bowl was on if you haven't seen that
smoking them but get some [ __ ] juju
juice without a fight yes smoking a
number these cigars I've never even
heard of an
these are [ __ ] good yeah yeah this
tastes like a cigar amazing and they
have different levels of nicotine so I'm
not a smoker so I'll get I got zero just
to try it out it tastes the same it's
great Vegas I don't feel like an [ __ ]
no more now you go to a casino feel like
an [ __ ] no mom it's discrete you know
whatever lease it saves you you don't
you know why hate getting cigars cuz I
put in a baggie in my pocket yeah no I
can't
so when do you have time to actually sit
there for four [ __ ] hours get a little
well on the East Coast they have cigar
lounges or like whether it have like
nice leather furniture and you can get a
drink that's really fun they have one
right next to the Improv do they really
James and I used to go to fat stogies in
Studio City across the street from
Jerry's deli yeah I didn't know they had
them there was so much fun god damn it
what god damn it what happened for you I
didn't print it up my friend sent me a
poster a picture that's really a post
he's gonna give it to me in New York of
the number one pool hall in Cuba in 1951
like when it was booming dawg 200
[ __ ] in there dressed
impeccably like impeccably like no jeans
like suits on women with mix on little
things and champagne on buckets and
these [ __ ] a shootin pool and
you can see like the daylight come over
the beach and [ __ ] god damn Cuba 19
[ __ ] 51 isn't it crazy how Cuba used
to be like them this was the place this
was the place they all would go there
Kennedy would go there the mob would go
there everybody went to Cuba you know
actors ambassadors it was a good place
to go how long have a plane ride would
be from Miami like 20 minutes like how
long could it possibly be it's 90 miles
so it's from either San Diego that's
like not even the trip to Vegas they
have to do a circle just to feel okay
just to make it worth a you don't listen
man I don't know
before for for 9/11 the trip to Vegas is
40 minutes after 9/11 awesome that
became an hour tank plus they doubled
the price so those of those feet are
like 911 fees this times the plane of
Vegas has been 50 minutes behind and
they still got me here on time you know
I'll have from Vegas to Burbank they
know it's not that [ __ ] take a
security's route really I think yes why
would they do that because how guilty
would you feel if you took somebody for
a half hour from hit of Vegas it's not a
kill sizing 234 [ __ ] fuel the fuel
cost so much money they'd be crazy to do
that yeah they'd be crazy to do that
fuel is the number one problem with air
travel the reason why they have to jack
the rates up all the time is Jeff you'll
keep getting more and more expensive
are you serious as car fuel gets more
expensive jet fuel gets more offensive
Coffee was not that bad right now it's
not that bad right now do you remember
when Bush was leaving office yes Ron
White started flying commercial that's
when he got busted with weed because his
[ __ ] [ __ ] ex-wife I don't know her
maybe she's a nice lady I'm just on
wrong side but uh she she ratted him out
and said he was gonna be at the airport
with weed in his pocket so the cops met
him at the airport with his luggage and
busted him scrapping for a little bit of
weed yep let's take a little bit of weed
you could google it he eaten me he went
to [ __ ] I mean I don't know if he got
arrested went to jail but he definitely
got popped at the airport and is because
he was always flying private cuz he was
doing the [ __ ] blue collar tour just
balling out of control did you know Bill
Murray got arrested for weed I read that
today because I was reading something
about him and his relationship with the
guy who just died he got arrested was
like bales of weed bales it was it was a
lot I'm gonna have to look it up I've
read an article today about like their
relationship and he wasn't making he
wasn't paying rent and him and his
brother had like 17 something crazy like
huge amount of weed you know he took a
long time off of movies and Bill
Murray's got a brother who's a priest
like a big-time [ __ ] priest somewhere
like I've heard this a couple [ __ ]
times
Bill Murray sir is Irish he's on yeah
yeah Wow yeah he was arrested with ten
pounds
what year let's see 1970 whoa that's 110
pounds nearly 10 pounds that's before
acting that's reacting yeah amazing
yeah he got was it was that before
Saturday Night Live yes I know I was 73
74 75 he only got probation
you got five years probation yeah first
time offense 10 pounds 10 pounds a lot
of [ __ ] that Your Honor I can't stop I
can't stop smoking marijuana I need
white chicks can you tell the stories
well bringing guns back from Colorado to
New York every other weekend you know
bill knows the real deal man
when he played the guy first gonzo he
played the yes right the first thing not
whether buffalo buffalo arms he really
you know that's why I saw him I saw him
in [ __ ] Woody Creek diamond and he
was sitting with the dude he's preparing
for it yeah like I did a great [ __ ]
job in that movie that's not a pickle to
sleep on that ol buddy ever saw nobody
even knows that movie exists I have that
movie you have it at home I don't I do
Ron arrest Thompson fans yeah that is
when he answers the phone
when he's arguing with the dude he's
talking to him real mildly and he just
answer buddy goes wide yeah I lose it
every time I know where I saw that movie
the first time I you know were we with
the internet what we watching the honor
that people go lose brothers we were in
the brand watching Blues Brothers mayhem
Matt full Tron losing it I seen what had
the bar at the bar losing it that when
he play when they play and they get hit
with the bottles and they do stand by
your man [ __ ] Belushi was just on a
different level
oh yeah do you say it's the drugs I tell
you when you do that many drugs and you
wake up the next morning the next day
you're very unconscious the best days I
had as a salesman
one night I [ __ ] I felt my spine
tingling when nights that I [ __ ] felt
the electric jolt of cocaine I would be
a sports salesman and I would wake up
and go in and by 12 o'clock I've made
three grand isn't like a hangover what
is it like it wasn't it was a hangover
but I'm unconscious I really don't know
what I'm doing you know when you think
about things and you go into something
and you think about it you can't really
it's when you don't think about it yeah
well you're just flowing and I was just
flowing I would say Joey no nerves what
is it on Saturdays you always do great
and I remember I used to just not so
much coat then that I couldn't even get
sprays to open up my nose so it would
take two tissues and just stick them up
my nose so the drain and I would sit
there all day with two tissues they
would look at me and go what's up
[Laughter]
betting side beyond the phones talking
but even with cars my best days were
after a 10-hour [ __ ] binge it's on
you know Wow it's [ __ ] amazing yes
last thing I was telling you guys I
would say Dodger game my uncle now this
is the same uncle that we pulled guns on
each other 25 years ago this week is the
30th anniversary of you guys pulling
guns lolly guns on each other in night
September of 84 on Vermont boulevardier
really down here my uncle my mother's
brother
blood not like whoa what brother no
blood grew up together cube of the same
house
losing Glendale always has since I used
to come out here when I was a kid I used
to come out here when I was a kid when I
first came out here when I first came
out here I came out here when I was 8 9
and 10 and we go to Dodger games Sea
World
Malibu we'd go to his different jobs I
know my mother died I could have came
back with him but I was like California
I know my California I kept in touch of
them and then when I was 21 I said [ __ ]
New York people are looking for me I got
to get out of town so I came out here
and I tried to make give this a go you
know and he wasn't going for it Charo he
was like you got a room upstairs you got
a week to get your [ __ ] together you
don't get it together in a week you got
to go dog knows I got to hear my
mother's brother but he threw me out and
I couldn't take us I tried to rob I
couldn't go home with nothing so I
pulled guns we pulled guns the cops came
the cat came because I was robbed with
him as he pulled up he called the cops
in the cab team so I swore to God I go
next time I see I'm gonna [ __ ] shoot
you you [ __ ] I mean this was
terrible this was horrendous see
Newcombe from prison was at him I used
to call him from my alley
I used to talk yeah man it's it's the
podcast oh you walk five miles a day
listen to me gentlemen he brought to pop
it up up at the puppet the seeds to the
game they're like little apples to dry
apples they have the highest level of
life the accidents that known and any
[ __ ] fruit dry apple some I don't
it's not a dry apple do not quote me on
this
it looks like an app where he has to go
to Huntington Beach to buy him he
brought walnuts organic walnut and
something else for the last 50 years he
doesn't eat like a human person he eats
like a [ __ ] Gentile from Studio City
but he goes nuts like organic milk
because home milk makes you swell up you
inflame I mean he didn't stop every time
I see him it's a [ __ ] here beaten he
brings his own eggs to a diner and makes
them cook them yeah he don't like
regular eggs like you he'd only don't
believe in eggs from the store you know
you're very different he's got a [ __ ]
him and get his own eggs or they gotta
eat organic grass I should have brought
you over some eggs
oh I could just know how delicious our
real [ __ ] it I get almost a dozen
eggs a day
yeah how great 24 chickens oh there's
tremendous they look different there the
yoke is like a dark orange and they
taste different they taste better I mean
I get them fresh fresh like I'm eating
eggs that just came out of a chicken
that day how long I never understood how
chickens do that do they have to have
sex because is it like sex or they just
keep blowing laying it no they lay eggs
every day if the hen [ __ ] them the eggs
are live and the eggs become a chick but
if the if the the rooster if the rooster
doesn't [ __ ] them then they just lay
eggs I don't have any roosters so the
hens just a lay eggs they're just duds
they lay them every day
all those it does yeah there does oh
they could never become a person person
never could become a chicken I didn't
know that either until I got chicken I
never ate because they look I knew they
did it every day but I was like but I
think why it's crazy that vegans won't
eat chicken eggs like they cannot become
a chicken it's impossible and look if
you go by my house my chickens are like
my friends like they come and hang out
like Jessica loves them their chickens
are the kids love them they're they're
[ __ ] their little animals man they're
hanging around the yard you've got
chickens you pick them up and everything
oh my god they're beautiful yeah I got
24 of them and you have a little place
for them and everything oh yeah they
have a big house they have a chicken
house I had it built they go wandering
around my yard the night they go back in
they go back in on their own no no drama
from the animals
there's been no not for my dogs no but
there's been coyote drama and Hawk drama
the Hawks eat them and the Hawks are
trying to get in on them but the area
where they are there's a lot of trees
and they go into the trees and so the
Hawks have to have an eight an area to
swoop in grab him and then swoop back
out and they're a little too big for
that so now but when they were little
there was one of them turned up missing
I'm pretty sure Hawk got one of them one
of the smaller ones was a long-ass time
ago but the coyotes coyotes go around
the fence and they look in every now and
I catch them looking in I'm gonna get a
[ __ ] pistol an air pistol to set them
up as my easy pool of cat food out there
think think
no my uncle makes everybody hands down
look bad like him so major yeah it's
amazing no rice no no nothing just he's
real healthy he's been Juicin for 50
years he's like these [ __ ] jackals
they think they invented something me
and Jack LaLanne how to talk 50 years
ago he told me about juicing did he
really ever talk of Technology Bunkley
Jack LaLanne was the he was the guy that
was doing that a long time ago he would
take like a [ __ ] giant bowl of
vegetables and juice and about juicing
down so my uncle said when he came out
here 50 something he came out here to be
somebody's maintenance man he was
working in New York as a as a
maintenance man a building and an actor
lived in the building that was a soap
opera guy and he wasn't got a big house
in LA could you come out there and be a
maintenance man there's a house there in
the back teeth they live back there I
live in New York anyway they came out
here when the guy had some TV show so my
uncle would go down to the studio and he
said he met he was like in Spanish it's
really funny he was telling how he was
an estimate rise with jackal and this
guy used to do push-ups with one [ __ ]
hand you know like the Cubans that's
huge he was a [ __ ] Savage and he
always said then that you always should
eat a carrot blended or something yeah
my uncle said what and onions
I mean I heard Jacqueline used to go
[ __ ] Arliss yeah garlic it's a [ __ ] and
he yeah he was the original juicer so
he's been Juicin he chooses he only has
a a certain he hasn't eaten sugar in 50
years the word is a Jacqueline would
[ __ ] everything that moves female or
male male oh you know when I was a kid I
remember waking up and that [ __ ]
had an exercise showing with the suit oh
yeah he had the suit so you never know I
don't jumpsuit that [ __ ] jumpsuit no
no he would you know he would he was
eating healthy before everybody he was
working out like deep into his 60s and
70s he was doing stunts when I'd first
say 60th birthday he towed like 60 boats
behind him
like swimming he'd uh he'd did a bunch
of really crazy [ __ ] like that like he
was an incredible fitness incredible
shape
yet for everything you couldn't go near
him even when he was older it was all
there it's I mean which makes sense
why would he be so motivated to have
such a great body like deep in those
fifties and sixties don't you know
you're [ __ ] horny as [ __ ] flying when
you throw metal around and [ __ ] push-ups
and pull-ups jumping you guys dick for
three or four people really - you really
do
when you lift weights and [ __ ] like when
I was going that that kettlebell gym I
really like the [ __ ] deadlift your
shoes
I had dick for days like I could jerk
off give somebody a stabbing and I'd to
have to bang one out again standing up
that's the worst we got a bang one out
standing up and you laughter I think
it's the dogs yeah there's something
pathetic about jerking off standing up
I've done that oh that's a disgusting
way when you have to bang one out of the
shower and maybe later I like hotels
because you lay down on your back it
just comes out you're like a family you
don't give a [ __ ] it's your own calm my
married friend says he has to do it into
the toilet well he doesn't on his iPhone
see the thing is - about like when
you're away like if you go away like if
you do like comedy or something like
that where you go on the road you come
back home and you know you miss your
girlfriend you miss your wife you're
looking forward to seeing her yet but
when you're with someone all the time
and you can't even jerk off cuz like
you're at work all day can't jerk off at
work you get home she's home you're
there together every night day-in
day-out the monotony and the grind and
then you're jerking off into a toilet
that this is just something just
defeating about it takes all the the
zest out of life you're just hiding in
the bathroom why are you in there for so
long
what are you doing otherwise let me I
have to get a q-tip what do you why is
the door locked
what are you doing you've been in there
for five minutes what are you doing
you know just concentrating jerking off
down downward jerking you don't want to
miss the toilet you don't want to shoot
all over the top you don't want to upper
deck your load I don't think I don't
think that's accurate about that I've
jerked off everywhere I have found a way
like this time just sitting anyway you
know what I got ten minutes right you
never walked off when you the trailer
fee effect oh I worked [ __ ] yeah you
never walked off when you want
everything in an office no my not you by
yourself you have a whack off driving
[ __ ] yeah I'm not not fully but I'm like
gotten horned up never
I can't imagine coming like no [ __ ]
why do I like you [ __ ] yeah you look for
an ol McDonald's bag you wiped that
[ __ ] sperm well I can't nervous when
the backseat is green in three [ __ ]
days
I only whacked off once while driving
and I after I jerked off while I was
driving I was like great now a jerk-off
in the car - I was thinking I was gonna
do this all the time
and I for whatever reason I only did it
once one [ __ ] thing I did at one time
it was when I was driving limos I just
lifted up my shirt shot my stomach put
the shirt down patted it down I was
talking to somebody today who had to get
a fertility testing and I'm surprised
more people don't miss like the cup I
just get into it and forget about the
cup it was really weird he was told me
the head like and I like an Apple TV
full of porn like a mostly a lot of
transvestite stuff how would he know how
much translate stuff they had people who
let's see what we got here yeah well
this one's not doing it for me he said
there wasn't a lot of girl-on-girl hey
that's all you're surprised about he
said it was mostly regular like big
boobs or gay and transvestites big boobs
or gay and transvestite
wow I wonder what their business where
was this weird part in LA I don't know
where he went but it was I almost got
tricked tonight by a transgender person
I was in subway before cuz I know this
animal is gonna kill me
this man I guess came in but I couldn't
tell from behind
had the best ass I've probably ever seen
on anything but then I changed the
t-shirt white jeans and a jacket I
didn't see the show here yeah I saw her
walking up and down yeah she's a hooker
she has but I heard it in their voice I
was like oh that's not a girl and then
she turned around like oh that's really
not a girl but I can't like the I got
tricked like have you ever been Jon you
got tricked if you suck this dick that's
how you got trigger you get Rick but you
just saw and said let me get my [ __ ]
together before she advertises me you
know if you ever want to see the really
transvestites you have to get up very
early in the morning go home late at
night and I'm Santa Monica and Vine it
is like [ __ ] the walking dead of
transvestites between maybe 4:30 and
like 8:00 in the morning Santa Monica in
fine that's a crazy like a vine Santa
Monica LaBrea Santa Monica Highland well
that whole area it's very strange not at
4:00 in the [ __ ] morning it is not
like it's 6:00 in the morning like I
used to go down after nine o'clock
Weight Watchers meeting on Sunday and
I'd still see them out from the night
before
they have Weight Watchers meetings yeah
you have to go to meetings I didn't know
that yeah you have to go to meetings so
it's like at Alcoholics Anonymous thing
yeah yeah cuz all they way you know they
talk about knowledge for an hour how to
avoid this how to avoid that and when
you go on vacation me to toast with the
baked potato you know a little [ __ ] like
that you know he toast with baked potato
I'm just saying you know what the [ __ ]
they just it's like 35 minutes you go in
you pay your dues and get the [ __ ] out
of it huh some people weigh in some
people don't man some people go down and
just to not lose weight at all it'll go
there every [ __ ] week just to get out
of the house it really is an amazing
thing you know but they have them like
at 9/11 isn't that what happens with a
lot of people they get involved with
almost anything like there's a lot of
things that people do with it just
trying to get out of the house whether
it is going bowling and I remember I
went to a Renaissance Fair once and
there was you know everyone in the
Renaissance Fair pretty much everyone
talks like they're from another time
right there are milady
you know the style won't you know they
speak that way but this one lady
wouldn't do it she was breaking
character like she was just there to
hang out and she was complaining about
her husband her husband won't take his
medicine I went to the pharmacy I got
him all this resident and this other
chick was pissed off that she wouldn't
you know go along with it she goes uh
sorry I don't understand what does that
mean about medication and prescriptions
what are they speaking about like she
was speaking you know she was like
trying to pretend that the other [ __ ]
was like mad at her like come on cut the
[ __ ] I'm talking about my I'm trying to
complain here she was just trying to
complain she just she wasn't into being
in the Renaissance Fair she just wanted
to get the [ __ ] out of the house and
[ __ ] and whine and so she put on some
crazy European outfit and went out to
this Renaissance Fair I was just trying
to treat it like it was just a normal
coffee shop just hang out and whine
about things my dad does it in Florida
he retired he moved down there and was
bored he does this like community Patrol
thing in a police car like the Sheriff's
Office has it he doesn't like four hours
a week they gave him a real uniform he
goes around to the hey you had to learn
the codes for things what's his name
Zimmerman that's where it sits we had
this conversation on your podcast about
I always believe that you want to do
something you know you just keep showing
up you know and I thought about it after
like when I lived in Seattle Seattle was
my real open mic era you know so Mondays
and Tuesdays let's say 20 people with it
that's what the list was 20 people who
buddy have six minutes seven minutes the
last two guys probably had 10 minutes I
said those 20 people some of them would
just dare to fill a void mm-hmm but do
you go find know that that's what works
for them yeah they have a local job they
just wanted to calm me as a hobby you
know but that happens and everything
yeah went to the acid [ __ ] it I was
sitting at
I had nothing going on I said you don't
want to try these knee pads because when
I tried the knee pad first after the
surgery it didn't fit so I put this knee
pad on Tyler Fitz I put my pants on just
go to jujitsu just do hip escapes that's
it just make the legs go that way
make them go this way once I'm get tired
and get the [ __ ] out of it dawg I was
drenched and it's a big difference
between elliptical sweat and jujitsu
sweat hmm you just do sweat you know and
you got a lotta mitts on your neck and
[ __ ] that's coming out of your head
poisonous [ __ ] it's tremendous you're
doing noogie right no I do gauge when
you do Agee and you know you're you're
working out when you take that game when
you get that big heavy thick canvas key
and it just soaked oh my god cuz I went
to pick it up just now see if I could
throw it in the hamper yet no man I'll
do wet oh that was so wet I was like
it's six [ __ ] hours later but it's
funny I went down 18 and Tuesdays and
Thursdays is a very small class compared
to their night classes but there's one
guy that walked into class dressed with
his gear ready no warmup doesn't have
never never been that 12:30 go sits now
his feet are always dirty sits down like
kungfu doesn't do hip doesn't do
anything warm-up sits there watches the
technique does it five times on each
side gets up bowels and walks off huh
that's why he just wants to do a couple
drills that's it and he works as a
security where you training at what
price on the boys it's right it's BMAC
they're right around the corner I'll
bounce like I'll go to V Mac but V Mac
doesn't have all the classes and I can't
do Wednesday nights I can't do Monday
nights I'm doing this so Monday days
I'll go to Higgins I'll shoot down the
Beverly Hills and not go to heon's I
went there for the whole month of August
mojo
so now when this gets better I'll go
Egan's at 11 it's 11 to 12 15 real quick
we're seeing the Beverly Hills behind
the tuxedo shop he can used to have a
place in like Redondo right no no no
that was the other brother that was
Hajer who's got the place by the ice
house that we own John John
yeah I think Carlos is in Dallas and
jean-jacques is in Tarzana
mmm jean-jacques is apparently opening
up a place in Austin to with Todd white
yes somebody's opening yeah cuz Todd
white was he's one of John jocks black
belts he's the artist he used to work
for Nickelodeon now he does this amazing
cocktail style like 1930s and 50s almost
cartoonish really cool stuff and he's
are super popular like he can't turn out
art enough like everybody wants to buy
Todd White's I went to a friend's house
and she had a Todd white thing on the
wall like years ago I was like this is
crazy it's my friend Todd's like this is
nuts she's making Bank right oh because
somebody was telling me the whole thing
it's it's ridiculous fallen out of
control artists it's amazing well that's
it that art thing is a weird world but
once you become like a guy that
everybody wants to have a piece I want
to Joe original Joe Diaz and you know
becomes like a thing that these aren't
people I was talking to a friend who
explained it to me and he was saying
that they manufacture it what they'll do
is they'll they'll get an artist and
then they they they take a bunch of
people that they already have
connections with like really big people
that buy 50,000 dollar paintings like
nutty and they buy them is investment
oka because they like art they buy them
as investments they buy them because
it's a hobby it's a thing for them it's
like you know those crazy wine people
those people that are like that with art
they're crazy art people there's by art
and the gallery will contact them and
say listen there's a guy who's coming up
he is phenomenal and just I want to gift
you a piece because we know you're such
a loyal customer and I'm gonna give to
you a twenty-five thousand dollar
painting you know because for a guy
who's buying millions of dollars where
the art because a lot of these guys
actually do buy millions of dollars
worth
art from a particular gallery gifting a
guy a twenty five thousand dollar piece
is just an investment but it's not
really a twenty-five thousand dollar
piece it's a twenty five thousand dollar
piece because they say it's twenty five
thousand dollar piece so you gift four
or five guys these these big high roller
guys these pieces now they're in the art
community well who's that that's an
original Joe Diaz
yeah the gallery gave it to me it's a
twenty five thousand dollar piece the
guy's incredible Wow yeah he's having
and there's gonna be a gallery show in
October so then they put on the gallery
show in October the prices have already
been established and then you see 35,000
nobody flinches and they just start
buying them like hot cakes why because
these big shots already have the $25,000
pieces so they create this bizarre
bubble this bizarre market and they do
it by giving these like really big high
rollers expensive pieces it's really
fascinating it really is yeah smart I
mean they just look you know what it is
it's like it's a hostel they figure out
how to get in with these people they
figure out how to just how to make it
like I was hearing about um there's
certain handbags that that really rich
broads are really into these certain
bags I don't remember the name of it
but you have to have a relationship with
the people that sell the bags in order
to even buy a bag like you can't just go
in off the street you have to have
already been a client so you have to buy
a bag to get it back so it becomes
exclusive so because it's exclusive
they're selling these bags for like
$50,000 I'm like how the [ __ ] is someone
paying fifty thousand dollars for a
purse it's a bag it's not a Ferrari you
can't drive it it's not there's nothing
there's no crazy engineering involved in
this it's not like a watch that some guy
made by hand and he's got [ __ ] giant
goggles on it takes six years to make a
one now it's a [ __ ] purse but because
they've engineered this exclusivity
they've arranged it and they just they
work that market that market of people
with incredible wealth because
especially where we are we don't even
realize it you know you grew up
you know in a place where it was like
blue-collar and you know nobody was
multi-multi-millionaire but there's
places like Brentwood or you know
bel-air where you might have a hundred
people in a mile radius that have
$100,000,000 like that's not uncommon I
mean there's insane money in certain
areas were you looking at these homes
there's twenty five million dollar home
that's a 30 million dollar estate this
house is going for 50 million I mean
there's a lot of that in this area and
all they have to do is tap into those
folks because they have insane
disposable income and what's expensive
to you or I it's not expensive to them
it's nothing $25,000 for painting ain't
[ __ ] for them so they figure out a way
to weasel into that world and then it
becomes about that world then it becomes
about that exclusivity you know this is
an original job Diaz look at that on the
wall very nice where'd you get it well
you know the gallery you know they've
got a show coming up I love this use of
color and they just are trying to find
ways to spend their [ __ ] money I mean
they might have a house in Costa Rica
they got a [ __ ] house in Canada you
know I mean like there's a lot of those
people in LA that are just stupid rich I
heard that there's like a social network
now they have to pay like 10 grand to
get into is that have you heard about
that no what's your call trying to find
it right now here we go
social network that cost $9,000 gets
free stupid okay what are you gonna get
out of this social network are they
gonna blow you
we called metropolitan metropolitan it's
six thousand a joint and then an
additional three thousand that renews
annually to keep to continued access
everybody joining you have to be 21
let's see if it says they're not sharing
how many members of course I know
there's two people in it oh my god you
have to be a real [ __ ]
I can't admit where the pen breaks in a
$50,000 bag what if I nail polish thing
spills
what are you dog pisses on oh my god
thoughts amazing
to the park I go to the park every
[ __ ] day but yeah they I went to the
park and I heard women talking and they
were talking about they kept prices in
the area that they went shopping
what about that man oh my god
I looked at the web page and it was just
I thought I was dizzy I was on the swing
and they want you know my baby was on
the swing and I was bugging out so I
could hear them talking on the swing and
they were talking about how you have to
get on the list to get your kid into
this [ __ ] daycare like we have to
know somebody and then they have to get
you on the list
and it's exclusive in van nuys going
like how did they make it exclusive like
what do the kids do that's different is
there a security guard then they [ __ ]
free [ __ ] you know give him a chef right
I mean are they gluten free meals I mean
you know I think I want my kid to get a
little [ __ ] dirty I mean but they
were totally I heard them talking about
percentages let's say every other day
care around this 200 a week this plays
wild like 1,200 a week 1,200 away
something just [ __ ] ridiculous
something just ridiculous and Van Nuys
you know and it's the same thing how
they just make it exclusive
it's exclusive you have to get on a
[ __ ] list a list for what so my kid
could play with [ __ ] blocks hmm maybe
it's just they just have a great setup I
mean maybe it's just like great out of a
setup could it be twelve hundred a week
sounds insane well that's something with
comparison to what a regular daycare is
this is how much more wise Wow and they
had like just you have to get on at six
months and if your child's not
potty-trained and I went home and I'm
thinking about I asked my wife but she
was oh yeah they got him all over like
that that you the one by the house by
Marie et Cie yeah that's a Christian
Church that have to wait list a Jewish
people to put that kids in that day care
because the daycare is just that good
what about pet hotels where they give
them like TVs and beds have you heard
about that
like an all-day animal
well the you know it's it's you know and
listen man it's whatever the [ __ ] you
pay for whatever you believe man you
know it's just [ __ ] amazing it's
twenty-five thousand for a picture
whatever the [ __ ] artist and you sit
there and I've been to those things my
buddy in New York is like a great framer
his shop isn't the Lower East Side and
whenever I go back he gives me a hug and
he kisses me on both cheeks I mean it's
not his fault we were 15 in summer
school so I play his game I go over
there when I was broken 84 I [ __ ]
made deliveries from frames and pictures
and [ __ ] and you know every night they
go to these things I've been with them
where they go and they sit and they look
in front of a picture and they make
believe they drink wine these people
give you some of this they give you you
know sushi it's a social thing it's a
social thing it's a it's a big social
thing to be an art collector because it
shows that you have a certain amount of
taste you know like if you if you're
into obscure art that's a Jackson
Pollock mmm amazing amazing I love what
he's doing here's his concept is
incredible I didn't know there were any
current artists getting that much money
oh I thought it was older people no you
just have to be in that circuit you just
have to be in that I was over a bob
gurcius house Bob Hirsch is the [ __ ]
guy owns Kirsch he's the guy that I had
to get on the phone with they were
trying to get me to apologize Earthman
see and him and him in the wig and I'm
out over his house in aspirin it's a
long [ __ ] time ago and he's got this
thing on his wall and it's like a bunch
of pieces of paper like it looks like
tissue paper glued onto other paper and
like a lot of paint and I look at it I
go I go disease is this something as his
kid made and someone goes no that's a
blah blah blah and I go what's that and
he goes that's worth $30,000 I go what
the [ __ ] are you saying I mean it wasn't
even big news it was like as big as that
Longest Yard framed poster you have up
there that thing you know and it was it
wasn't like an enormous piece that took
[ __ ] 50 years to make
no it's like a normal-size painting it's
like bunch of [ __ ] tissue glued to a
thing and some scribble it was abstract
modern art you know that's what they
call it abstract or [ __ ] nonsense
unless it was your kid you know if your
kid made it it would be cute it made
sense to me I thought it was his kid
like what the [ __ ] is this this is
$30,000 I think when they throw their
[ __ ] like the like the counterfeiters
living dying that way he would draw the
artists yeah them on fire yes died out
lay that [ __ ] movie was hung in
the morning at 6:00 and the more I put
on a que toi news let me see what else
is on I'd [ __ ] put that's why
remember I put that part on it starts
with him burning a picture he burnt the
[ __ ] pictures in the beginning at the
end you know there's those [ __ ] guys
that do the art oh the picture because
it just meant to my closure and yours my
god you gotta get your [ __ ] together guy
it's [ __ ] all over for you you know
it's the art world is filled with a lot
of pretentiousness but just uh just art
itself calling yourself an artist being
an artist wearing a scarf when they call
themselves an artist yeah that's where
my fan and they justify by going you
know you're an artist
I'm sibling but there are artists what
there are artists but these really
pretentious artists they [ __ ] up the
whole concept of being an artist
you know like lip Quentin Tarantino is a
[ __ ] artist okay that's a guy who
creates badass [ __ ] movies he's
it's an art to him you know I mean like
you know fill in the blank Richard Pryor
was an artist you know he was a real
artist he created art on that stage but
some [ __ ] they they say you know
I'm an artist
and you just go yeah you just want to
throw up on them yeah it ruins the word
rule it ruins the term you know we are
the star yeah we're very finicky what
the [ __ ] you know I'm an artist I just I
can't beat
down I'm an I'm a free spirit you don't
consider yourself an artist Joe oh yeah
every morning when I wake up I'm gonna
go see artists and so how well you are
an artist but you're economic and the
comic supersedes everything else being a
comic is you know it's a different
communities without a doubt in art form
but it's being a comic is the most
important aspect of the art form and
that eliminates any possible pretension
there's no problem you can't be
pretentious to be a [ __ ] comic you're
a [ __ ] joke Slayer you know that's
what we do you know just listen I could
never I have invited this wedding I
think I told you I didn't invite this
wedding usually I won't [ __ ] go to a
wedding but it was in town I don't go
and it'd be a nice date night for the
wife and we get to the wedding other
people like oh my god was so happy you
made it we put you in the celebrity
table the celebrity table [ __ ] Gwen
Stefani and a [ __ ] husband and the
black dude from Rocky Apollo Creed
Apollo Creed and Carl Weathers call
weathers and you know just a bunch of
other people are lucky
yeah like this level celebrities yeah
like just you know once define he's
pretty big yeah that's before she got
pregnant like this is this about two
years ago maybe she still she was huge
was she here yeah I got peas right no
that's that's for you no doubt yeah you
know but uh no it was just really weird
that that word right there and it's just
you know man every time I like I hear
[ __ ] like that like somebody comes
actually like today I was washing the
collar and somebody came in and said
something about how I saw you on nurses
oh and I want to say I wish you woulda
saw me when I arrived
I really don't I wish you would've saw
me when I robbed the [ __ ] the changed
thing for blind kids from a Carvel one
thing because I was sure four bucks for
a [ __ ] 20 cycle weed Oh Sonia I
wanted to tell Carvel cuz I knew they
always had like fives and [ __ ] so I
bought like the baseball Cup with the
ice cream minute to give me like the
Kansas City Rose did you get pissed off
I stole the [ __ ] can with the goods
you know and that's why I think about
whenever somebody says uh wow you know
that role you have in the movie and I
feel like saying god you're gonna have a
[ __ ] idea
like what are you getting why is it bad
that they like you for a role in a movie
like what is it that you you you want to
like redefine yourself none what
something about redefining myself it's
just about you know we're talking about
my uncle taking me to this game I tried
to rob me 25 years ago at gunpoint
whatever we don't talk about that like I
wanted me to tell the story on the
storytelling I said re if you don't know
my uncle he don't talk about it he very
like I apologized him on the podcast and
he wouldn't even he don't go that bro
he's never told me he loved me
I tell him all the time I love you deal
all right I'll see you know just not
[ __ ] around
he called me ran out yesterday he goes
cuz I thought I couldn't go to the game
don't work he was the only person I
wanna go to the game with with you not
even my son because I think I'm on CA 76
he's my mother's brother you know but
yes it on the way back you know that
wish your mother would grow up to see
what you became she goes at the funeral
you were lost kid
but when you came here every time I look
through your eyes I thought the Charles
mance Nancy because I thought about John
Watson
my fellow he what good do if you were to
kill her because you were either gonna
kill somebody he was telling me bro he
that's what he you know he called me out
nobody had ever called me out for I was
21 years old your name right after my
mother died he might be so sensitive
don't say them to him he might snap my
uncle said I don't give a [ __ ] if your
mother died that was five years ago put
it behind you it's over they say in the
free world [ __ ] I ain't giving you a
[ __ ] dime but when he said that to me
last night that you know it really hit
home because you had killers on you
really kills him that you were gonna
kill me that [ __ ] night you woulda
killed yo you would kill me for $500,000
well we became friends you were
definitely a different guy in the late
90s well but you reminded me of
everybody that I knew from the pool hall
like I love being around you because you
were like but what I hated most when I
first came to LA was that when I was in
New York and when I was in Boston I was
surrounded by you know East Coast people
that were either comics or they were
martial artists or there were pool
players it was like there was a there
was a grit to them there was a fun there
was a I could talk to them you know
there's there was real conversations to
be had and then coming out here
everybody was like preparing for it like
we were downstairs those people with
their scripts they're preparing and
they're sitting there and I'm and I'm
seeing them going over their lines going
over the thing I'm like this is hell
this is hell
like this preparing for for a role and
being in the the whole the whole
Hollywood scene like trying to get
people to like you and hire you for
things it's
weird world it's a weird world and here
is this guy hanging out the comedy store
there was a total hustler I mean you
were a total hustler you know and we
became friends like immediately like we
became friends like right away I
remember bringing you around the [ __ ]
news radio said like who is this guy
this is [ __ ] menacing guy in a
leather jacket that keeps eating all the
shrimp and you know for me it was even
the Comedy Store that we loved was very
goofy how was goofy step back we saw it
a couple of weeks ago I've been taking
Lee with me and I gonna come down you
know my foot come to the store and it
was great the first three or four times
and he sat there when you know he I got
a tag for you oh that was the worst it
was the worst night I saw Tony I had a
calm and apologize the next day Tony
Hinchcliffe well he was with you in
Sacramento uh-huh Quan apologize why
because I had to get the [ __ ] out of it
totally came up to my mind Tony I love
you I've seen it and I was telling you
someone's telling you they had a tag for
you well one night with Lin family will
get ready to leave in like hold on then
like listen man I heard that joke and we
gotta give you this tag you should say
me look I'm saying this I don't even
know and Lee's and me and Lily's like
that was [ __ ] weird and then the next
night we went down again and that's what
the guys are saying we have this idea
for a TV show
Oh oh my god and you're like I just get
on stage I just you know you're walking
to your car you're not even thinking
about a TV show yeah you're thinking
about how you should have said the
instead of cat [ __ ] of course and then
we have a word and he was right there
mm-hmm this idea for you for a TV show
not even how are you right what have you
been up to and he looked at me we were
high as [ __ ]
which really kills you when you're at
the commies know somebody's trying to
sell you something didn't Tony
Hinchcliffe came and I thought Tony I'm
like I can't even you know I gotta get
out of here to blow up the Highness the
set the people trying to sell me a TV
show and the people that are trying to
sell you things at the Comedy Store
most likely they never sold [ __ ] before
they just have an idea and they think
they're gonna come to you and that's how
they're gonna do a TV
show brighten it was just the idea we
looked at each other while they [ __ ] I
mean it was just so I understand that
like at the comments was always that one
person that you find warmth in and I
found that with you because everybody
had to calm everybody at that time was
looking to get on a show too quick Tommy
there was a big of that people would get
a TV show and that was it yeah and it
would have that happen like four or five
times and here's this guy that tapes a
great show and after the 10-hour 12
hours shoot still comes in does his 15
that was setting the original on the 12
o'clock I couldn't figure it out
most people would just go home and go
[ __ ] stand-up that's below me you know
you know and it's really weird the
people that have stuck it up and we'll
always be stand-ups like I always give
those guys respect don't come back to it
after the show got cancelled and do Stan
yeah Wow your show is on you tell your
agents hey those weeks that you don't
have me up at Warner Brothers I want to
be out the whole [ __ ] summer I want
to do this I don't know welder the show
doesn't want you to curse onstage say
any [ __ ] jokes on stage no [ __ ] you know
Saget - yeah no [ __ ] so you have to and
here I'm watching this guy that's going
against everybody else he's going
against what everybody else believes
everybody wants to use to call us
someone means to the end of an end for
the means means to a means to an end
that's it that in my life that's not how
my self to me and if I got on the show
that just helps me that'll help me get
up there and it gets easier now when I
go to a club in Iowa my dream was to get
in a car and pull a Mitch Hedberg and go
to all these clubs just drive across
country one time you know be on a TV
show do two 26 episodes but once that
shit's over with getting a Congo bon
voyage I'm on here and just go across
the country and you see a funny bone
jump in there you see comedy catch jump
in there
you see a comedy saloon jump in there
you see a pizza place with an open mic
and you're a Minneapolis [ __ ] to jump in
then you do that for six to seven weeks
and as a stand-up comic and people go I
just thought you were on TV
I didn't know you were this [ __ ]
funny oh this is what this is what I do
I didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't tidy when
I was growing up I was watching Charles
Bronson
I love Charles Bronson I loved when he
killed somebody I loved all that [ __ ]
with to cheer me for me with the fly and
and then but I never thought I was gonna
do that I thought that I would always be
an extra if they ever used me I thought
that we're gonna come to the comedy
store and say hey you you want to be in
my movie
you know I'd watch Hollywood nights you
ever see Hollywood nights at Tony Danza
Michelle Pfeiffer you see will be all
the people around him on comics in the
Comedy Store
Arlis TK Carter is the black guy that's
doing the fraternity run the dude who
had the show once on a married man Mike
binder he's the [ __ ] the kid who has
the mind of a married man mind of a
married man he's the [ __ ]
Hollywood nights is a famous place is
closing down on Hollywood Boulevard but
these are all of these Hollywood nights
you they they have to I didn't forget
it's just but this seems when they take
these black guys and they put sheets on
them they make them walk a little white
man I mean it was just crazy and the
people pissing the punch but if you look
at all the car man that movie they just
went into the store and picked up a
bunch of [ __ ] one night and put
them in that the same thing with Gabe
Kaplan we will grew up with the same
thing with Jimmy Walker you know suppose
they cut the deal to good time in the
back and one of the boots there Freddie
Prinze that's what we came from but you
always remain the stand-up you always
that was your roots when I came here
they I got here and they said are you
gonna go for an audition from my
peteyboo I know nothing about that about
commercials I thought they said
commercials and [ __ ] my eyes know
what the shock emerges like Amy
seriously I'm not [ __ ] commercials I
came in Italy your face is great for
commercial okay yeah yeah I don't know
think I didn't even know I never even
thought about shooting [ __ ]
commercial I got a friend of mine was
analyzed that was that your your first
big movie basically basketball
basketball that's reliable
that's when I first didn't want the NYPD
blue didn't get it and as I was walking
by a door Lenny pops up she was you here
for your audition I guess so give me a
sheet of paper I read it and boom I
booked three weeks of five grand I never
saw nothing like that in my life
why I snorted every penny and then I
robbed the [ __ ] rollerskates I robbed
a different pair of rollerskates every
[ __ ] day all right everything when I
returned them at Five Guys what is that
the five sports watch guys think I'm
[ __ ] kidding you I would get to my
room that'd be a size 13 and where I put
them back in the box and clipping the
lady would come a wardrobe every day for
three weeks every day come back again
Thirteen's and I started giving me size
12 we don't know what I have nor 13 me
neither
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] going then
twelve I was coming home with band-aids
Devin forty a pop plus tax when I
returned them and they were safe every
day the same sporting guns are you doing
what happened your grandma gave me this
we could hide you though what do you
want cash in check let me get some cash
to stop and get gas by the time I quit
by the time I stopped shooting I was
down for like a size eight
the truck let's rock the rollerskates
was missing a Chunkin I wish I was lying
to you I wish I was trying to just be
funny and be cute this is how crazy I
was you're absolutely right I was a
stone-cold hustler and I knew it it was
like well you remind me a lot of my
friend Johnny right you always said yeah
you remind me a lot of him you were just
uh you both didn't give a [ __ ] this a
lot of people pretend to not give a [ __ ]
they're pretending but you know then
little things will come out and you
realize so they kind of put on an act
but you would you would say so
you just tell me stories about things
you just done or I would see you you
know come out of the bathroom at the
Comedy Store with some [ __ ] crazy
broad and it was funny just funny times
it was just funny it was just you're a
real for me you were like a real
connection to what I was missing
like back in the East Coast cuz the
Comedy Store at that time was all these
like bode acts it was like guys that
would do like cruise ships and they
would sing they would have like songs
they would sing it was just it was a lot
of [ __ ] for every damon wayans that
would come in every real comic that
would stop by there was a lot of like
really bad comedy for a few years there
from like 94 to like I would say like 96
97 there was those were bad times at the
[ __ ] Comedy Store man but something
happened it's like they come in dips and
cycles because I remember when I first
came there I was really disappointed I
first came out there to do a pilot me
and Jim Breuer we did this thing in 93
it was called hardball and Breuer played
the this this mascot for his team and
you know we were hanging out together
we're shooting this pilot and we want to
go in the store and we were like this
place is dog [ __ ] like neither one of us
we weren't paid regulars there we're
just comics from New York so we went and
watched the show we just hung out the
back were like this is [ __ ] terrible
always going up do you remember anybody
I don't want to say names because some
of them are still alive
they weren't really black for one of
them had a three in his name right right
right right but it wouldn't leave for a
while detectives you believe that
meditech this Tupac really it's gotten
to a shootout there one night oh yeah
in the main room in the main room huh
someone shot at him in the main room at
the main room yeah he shot at someone
who was very blurry but it was was it mo
bettah Monday's was it no this was how
it was yeah at Tuesday's this man before
was before Fat Tuesday yeah those guys
from Fat Tuesday is still around the st.
Louis they good dudes man there's a good
yeah it was I heard I didn't know I
heard it just go wait here the guy Torry
take it over
maybe 97 96 when I got there 97 that was
already established and the guy saw me
at the Laugh Factory made me go up and I
ate a [ __ ] bag of [ __ ] debt and I
yeah that I twisted around
I just went black and twisted around it
was great as I went to walk off Richard
Pryor came I sat down and I said listen
you know whatever I don't matter when
I've listened to you it was the first
time I heard [ __ ] crazy or whatever
when I saw him I said that was it guys
that was it for me like I don't know
nothing like I heard that and I went
immediately and bought it and went home
he said this dog yeah I told him I said
to him from the stage why I walked
though he was already foolin he had
three people around his head up but just
to see him and then I knew I was home
you know I knew I was home that's how I
knew I was like god damn did you ever
see him when he did sets are you there
for them no no
that was weird he did a bunch of sets
where before he died I followed him
almost every show almost every show he
did mitts he threw me up after him
because yeah I had to figure out like
strategies to get the audience to laugh
because they were so depressed because
they saw they had seen the greatest of
all time and he was just gone he was a
shell of himself and he he could barely
talk like he was he they had to crank
the mic up like and he just be like Oh
[ __ ]
sometimes love me back like there was no
jokes I mean that was like a whole joke
that was a beginning setup punchline he
would drink wasn't supposed to be
drinking he was on medication you give a
[ __ ] you just drink anyway and he would
go onstage and then he would do his time
you know whatever it was 20 minutes or
so and sometimes more whatever he could
whatever he had the energy for and then
it would take them several minutes to
carry him from the stage to the back of
the room and Marilyn's husband Manuel
Martinez there Dave and Chuy would help
him and they would you know get one
under each arm and they would walk him
through the room and then they would put
him in his wheelchair when they got to
the end of the showroom original room
and I would go onstage and he didn't
bring yeah you know Jeff Scott would
bring you up from the side so Jeff Scott
would bring me up from the side and you
know from the piano and you go on stage
while everyone's like clapping and he's
walking out here I was nobody you know
some unknown [ __ ] idiot it wasn't
even that good at comedy yet I was
terrible and I had to go on after
Richard Pryor but I had to develop like
Joe I developed lines to say to like to
make fun of the fact you just saw the
greatest community of all time and know
the unknown white guy a lot of [ __ ]
let down and I just had to like I had a
whole shtick that I would do about what
this is a letdown like blah and I was
like like that's as if you just did that
and then did this like I had a whole
thing like making fun of myself for
happening go on after Richard Pryor how
many times did you follow him before you
decided he got to do that oh I had to do
it immediately
I did because I bombed the fur by bombs
several times going on after him and it
wasn't just that I sucked because I
definitely wasn't very good
but it was also that the room was somber
every time I only really did really well
like a couple of times the other times
was just survival but I you know I
probably followed him I think he did
like five or six weeks of sets there so
I might have had to follow him 1520
times I don't know I don't know how many
times it was because they're so long ago
it was late 90s but there was a bunch of
times when I used to go on right after
him when you I mean I was a kid and my
parents turned me under Richard Pryor
they took me alive at the Sunset Strip
when I was a kid man I don't know how
old I was but I couldn't have even been
13 it was like I was like 12 or
something like that whatever I was and I
remember sitting in that movie theater
dying laughs and hold it onto my stomach
watch and look it around at one time
while the film's plan was looking around
and all these people like falling
forward in their chair and I remember
thinking to myself all the funny movies
that I've ever seen all like Blues
Brothers and all that kind of [ __ ] I've
never seen anybody laugh like this I've
never been to a movie where someone
laughed like this and then I've realized
like stand-up comedy's incredible I was
like this guy is just talking
he doesn't have special effects he
doesn't have any music playing while
he's talking he's just talking and we
are dying laughing and that probably was
what planted the seed of me doing
stand-up I didn't really think about
doing stand-up for real until I was 21
tell us 20 and then I waited until I got
my 21st birthday because I couldn't go
to a nightclub before I was 21 but being
there all those years later after I done
stand-up for like probably six or seven
years at the time six years maybe and
then being in there with Richard [ __ ]
Pryor
and having it go on after him over and
over and over gonna like this is so
bizarre it's like the weirdest sort of
patchak passing of a torch thing not
even a passing a rite of passage maybe
or something like my own rite of passage
like Here I am in front of my comedy
Idol like if I had to choose like the
one guy that was like the most
influential to me I mean Richard Pryor's
right up to probably not one guy it's
like him in Kennison like the most
influential to me so to see him when it
was over like that Tommy a lot of [ __ ]
would you want to be up on stage of you
were 75 not like that there's no need
for it but I would only want to be on
stage if I was entertaining like Carlin
was entertaining - the [ __ ] day his
heart stopped how old was he when he
passed George looking up I want to say
he was in his late 70s but I might do no
I think maybe 69 or something right than
that really
he died he was 71 Wow just 71 you know I
think that if for you if you're a
stand-up I mean I'm not gonna tell you
when you I'm not gonna call you just 76
and Joey Joe stop bored I would know I
think I'm not [ __ ] entertaining but
you're in that house I mean if that's
what keeps you alive that's what it
would keep guys like I saw live well
that's one of the reason why I like to
do a lot of different [ __ ] - I don't
like having all my eggs in one basket no
no no but you know what I'm saying you
know today let me tell you something I
did something that I said I gotta go I
just had to go I just wanted to just
touch the mat oh dude you said you just
happened it's the same way when me would
stand up well I know I'm gonna bad mood
and things ain't going right this
refrain working just [ __ ] Facebook
ain't working you know he's [ __ ] hot
out that means I gotta get on stage
right I got something to talk about
that means that's my therapy and then
you two three four nights and you're
back to [ __ ] normal your ph is
balanced and all that [ __ ]
the difference is you're really funny
right now and you know Richard Pryor was
my opinion one of the if not the best
ever top two it's between I give
Kennison the best ever for a year I
think for one year Kinnison was the best
ever but I think prior overalls the
greatest comic of all time and then he's
not he's not there anymore man what he's
the violation and Lenny Bruce well Lenny
Bruce is probably the most important guy
because he was the guy who went to jail
for obscenity what would argue it in
court Carlin went to jail for two he was
also the guy who like he set the path
you know he started the whole that kind
of stand-up the kind of you and I do the
kind when you go on stage and just
honest about [ __ ] like he started that
that was all him and you know Hicks and
Kinnison they worshipped him they
worshipped Lenny Bruce and the way I
kind of found out about Lanny Bruce was
actually Kinnison had Lenny Bruce's mom
yeah yeah yeah like managing him or
something like that right she for the
benefit for her she was on one of his
like on a thousand dollars and he was
Gaston yeah when I lived in Seattle II
did the heirs of Lenny Bruce and I guess
his mother had donated a picture and
they did this right I still had that
that was my all-time favorite pictures I
got the feature the last weekend of the
festival you know just having that
picture in your name interact you know
but know I'll always love Lenny Bruce
there's nights I find myself watching
you know old black-and-white Lenny Bruce
and giggling I like his style the
material might be not what it's dirty is
behind but his style it's a time capsule
time yeah I mean you're looking you're
essentially going back in time and
you're watching a guy who in that era
that was a that was an innocent world no
I mean no one understood what this guy
was doing you did
all those little things is what I really
like so there's a guy dig and he goes
that you know like and what kill me
about this whole thing is he's Jewish
yeah that's well that watch him I'm like
this is a Jew town in the world of his
dead people he did a bunch of [ __ ]
crazy Hitler Joseph he did some [ __ ]
brilliant [ __ ] oh yeah for people know
you were talking he got arrested for
saying [ __ ] on stage right wasn't that
it he was arrested several times for a
cent for a bunch of different things
that he said on stage and the end they
they kind of like took his career away I
mean he lost all of his money fighting
it in court and you know even when he
died his name wasn't clear he was still
going to court and they when he broke
down at the end there's videos of this
you could you could I bought a DVD of it
once or VHS tape at the time it was him
going over his court transcripts he
would be on stage with these pieces of
paper and talking about why the judge
was wrong it was essentially he was
doing a podcast about his court
transcripts and the audience was bombed
down man they were like give us dirty
Lenny you want to heat that's what used
to call him dirty Lenny we want dirty
Leonard talking about boobies she's got
boobies man we got those titties yeah
you know like he wanted a like he would
say things like that and people would
like that couldn't believe you saying it
you know this is the 1950s or 1950s and
he was just a complete unique thing and
it was influenced by a lot of the jazz
musicians or they were influenced by
heroin
it was influenced by jazz musicians he
was influenced by a lot of black guys he
was around a bunch of people that didn't
give a [ __ ] and he took that not given a
[ __ ] and brought it to comedy and
there's also this desire to describe the
world around him in accurate terms
instead of just telling a bunch of jokes
this desire to like make people laugh
and let them see the hypocrisy in the
world that they're living in so it was
him
who's Pryor who was like the most honest
about his life and his feelings and his
shortcomings and the coke and the
craziness and lighting himself on fire
and all that [ __ ] me he was the most
honest about the end in my opinion the
funniest he was just the best pray was
this the smoothest
I mean he just had he had jokes about
him having a [ __ ] heart attack
you mean that joke you did where he just
jet I'm like eating pork you would think
about that when you eat in that port I
mean he had jokes about everything you
have jokes about shooting his wife's car
about going to jail for shooting his
wife's car I mean here's a black guy in
like a racially divided world post 1960s
race riots Martin Luther King
assassination all that jazz and he's
talking about shooting his white wife's
car shooting her [ __ ] car pretty sure
his white wife yeah and it was her
because you only have me watch the
documentary that they put out a couple
years ago mm-hmm and you were talking
about live at the Sunset Strip didn't
you like bomb the night before the night
before yeah now it's like the most
amazing so yeah yeah well what does it
call omit the logic omit the logic when
he did live at the Sunset Strip the
first night it was horrific well he
probably was nervous yeah Oh was around
and then he went back that next and is
[ __ ] natural we saw well I think when
you whenever you filming something man
yeah yeah experience this recently know
when I was filming my special I did two
shows the first show was to kind of
tense and someone do shake heckled me it
was just tense still went well still got
a lot of laughs but it wasn't smooth and
then the second show was like any old
show someone heckled you when they knew
they were taping oh this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no in the middle of a joke about
people getting upset about jokes she
yells out prove it like I just put my
head down I go are you really hacklin I
didn't even like no you can't atrocity
to her I had to address it because it
was so loud it was so stupid that what I
should have done and what I'll do next
time I do any other filming I should
have gone on stage before the filming
before the show even started before Tony
Hinchcliffe went on stage and said this
is very important to me
I just I want this to be as normal a
show as possible so I just come out and
say hi first just please don't hackle me
this is just trick me doing this for
Comedy Central so enjoy yourself if you
think it's funny
please laugh thank you
much for coming and that would have been
smart instead the director did it and he
kind he did a goofy job instead of
saying don't talk during the show don't
heckle he said try not to interact with
Joe too much which was like yeah [ __ ]
Lightyear well which might my friend
couldn't direct it you know Anthony who
does all of them he had to do a UFC he
works for the USA when he's directed
every one of my specials and he couldn't
do it so we had to bring this other guy
and it's just he'd he had never done
that before we went on state he just
didn't have a said the right thing to
second show so there was a lot of
fuck-ups the audience was too bright we
had to figure out to turn the lights
down and make it like a regular comedy
club but when you're filming something
it's real hard to do like to nail it in
like ready go like Hicks if you watch
Hicks is special from London revelations
when he comes out as the Jimi Hendrix
music and then fire and he's a very
stiff it's very stiff through the whole
set and me personally as a fan of his
haven't seen him it's one of his more
stiff performances and it's because he's
got one shot at this for an HBO special
one [ __ ] shot and you're in London in
this giant 2,000 seat arena and you know
it's just it doesn't feel like a guy
loose up there
I've seen him loose up there it's a
different performance and it's the same
with I think pretty much anybody who
does a show like Katt Williams new show
a perfect example his show I saw his HBO
show but before his HBO show I saw all
that material someone filmed it from the
audience and put it on YouTube and it
was [ __ ] hilarious it was really
funny the HBO special was still funny
but it was very stiff especially in the
beginning you could see he was aware
he's being filmed he didn't he gave a
[ __ ] you know in a guy who's act is all
about not giving a [ __ ] he gave a [ __ ]
because the ready go [ __ ] this is my one
shot to do this right it's like that's a
lot of weird
unusual pressure it's not like a fight
or if guys are always used to being
under intense pressure now all of a
sudden this show as is extra weight to
it because it's being filmed
and this is gonna be it ready you got
one show go you know these 5,000 people
do you ain't sound five thousand people
twice so if you want to do it big you
got one [ __ ] show yeah you want to
come out the lion can only do one show
they're thought the Lions gonna dance
the cage behind you but for one show the
second show the line might break the
cage you might be [ __ ] mad you might
kill everybody that's crowd so we got
the lion cat but we got we got one shot
at this so let's uh let's keep it
together
everybody let's huddle well isn't Bill
Maher doing a live special yes he's
doing a live special right after he does
a live tough crowd not tough crowd the
[ __ ] is this thing
what's his show called real time he was
doing real time and then he goes right
from real time but it's kinda you know
it's kinda doing it as a gimmick but
he's so confident though and he does so
many live performances on his show and
he knows his audience you know I mean
like they know who he is and what he
does he's very he's very calm he could
pull it off yeah he wouldn't know what
yeah he wouldn't pull it off I mean
wouldn't even temp to pull it off unless
he thought he could somebody else has
done that too though somebody a live one
which brought me to life the first time
was something that anytime he did like
Oh George Lopez Lopez I'm sorry when he
came on ass I sold 18,000 the depression
what Mexican could do this sold this
[ __ ] out like he was like the
first five minutes of his act about
selling the the readout like during a
down oppression the 15,000 Mexican down
economy that was when he was at his PB
just for made sure rolling that was it
something I said and it was fine because
I was at his house where his brother was
a junkie that's how I discovered Richard
Pryor this kid was not known so and we
went up we had the Beatles on the white
out whoa he came and goes what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] listening to take that
[ __ ] off listen to this we don't were
gonna hear rock music and that's his
black guy talking I had never
experienced that I had seen on TV David
Brenner and
you know people like that but I hadn't
the Riddler the Riddler was a comedian
Frank Gorshin Frank gorshins
expressionist something in the 60s and
50s or something and you know I've seen
those guys but I had never heard those
words I never heard somebody say [ __ ]
and [ __ ] suck and you know I ain't
[ __ ] thank you with the Cape way look
when people's winter and that was
mind-boggling like that I went home and
bought it and I have to put on like Led
Zeppelin in those days you have a record
player so you could put a record on and
then put the records you want it on top
of that like a CD what he called him
random mm-hmm so you could when that how
I'm finished this one were trapped in
the neither will don't automatically in
your arm and it would start all over
again
so what you did was you invite your
friends over you smoke a little dope in
the yard and you put Richard Pryor
that's right you loaded yellow there's
not half of each other and if your mom
came in you had a drop fast you'd have a
drop fast because she was gonna hear a
[ __ ] he said [ __ ] every two minutes
that was gonna be a button that so you
had a pull the album in fact Frank
Cannella told the story well he called
the guy from sci-fi yeah he said lemon
my mother was mad at you because she
thought we were in the room listening
the music
you brought the album to my house I
think tells the story in the sixth grade
I go you guys listening to the Beatles
help get that [ __ ] off listening for
this and the heads almost exploded and I
thought I was always intrigued with it
never went to see alive till 1987 so a
friend took me and I was like impressed
but then I went the second time and the
dude had not written the joke in a year
same dude from Boston remembers in
Steven Wright Steven Wright never wrote
a joke in about one year and I remember
leaving there I was into drugs comedy
was not even on my radar and going you
know what [ __ ] that do it in a year he
didn't write a joke like I didn't know
nothing about comedy not he had a tough
act to write to write for so I was
pissed and that was always in the back
of my mind that's the beginning once you
say to yourself I could do that mm you
don't same and you give it a try and you
either fail and get hooked or you get
your [ __ ] lights kicked out or
whatever the [ __ ] whatever venture you
gonna try you know and I never thought
never guys never never never and here's
the weird thing if you really think
about yeah I got up on stage or I got
locked up but right before I got left I
left
Hollister lincoln-mercury and bold the
Hollister Chrysler Plymouth Jeep because
their pay plan suddenly took away my
demo didn't wanna do demos no more I got
in fact listen what this the kid I
kidnapped call me time to say hello he
left me a message envelop top messages
ship the kid I kidnapped I'd say hello
see what happens when you apologize but
before I kidnapped this dude I went to
that Subaru dealership before I
kidnapped to do it I went to the Subaru
dealership and while I was there you
know there was this dude that was a
white dude like a western white dude
like with cowboy boots on
he put a suit on he kind of looked like
Charles Bronson didn't say much I think
him and I got into a beef one time over
a car deal and we got to split it and he
was like he said something to me a buck
used with that deal and I was like
nothing was gonna happen I was and that
was it well a week later one day he took
me outside a lot and he was like I've
been watching you you're wasting your
life 16 years because I came back to
raise my kids I'm not a [ __ ] car
salesman I just needed some [ __ ]
something to do with my and he knows
I've seen a lot of [ __ ] comedians man
you should give it a shot
I'm gonna make some calls me to get you
on today [ __ ] stage the [ __ ] out of
here you stupid [ __ ] idea he was a
white guy guys he was a white wine
when a cowboy dude and he was lying
you're wasting no I have someone color
you shall least give it a try I was like
okay and then when I got locked up it
was just something I was doing without
knowing I was doing you know I was doing
the Sun without knowing I was doing I
would just talk [ __ ] in the kitchen
there'd be a black rice cooker I just
start going off on like what the [ __ ]
you guys doing and then at night I'd get
up on stage on movie night and I [ __ ]
talk about looking [ __ ] leave his
green shirt on what the [ __ ] is your
products and I just go around the room
and the black guys would go crazy you
know and I didn't even know what I was
doing there was like my got out of there
there was no Def Jam no I didn't think
about that [ __ ] I was just having fun
and they would always send it back you
but when you get out of here you got to
do it Dawg you gotta do it and it was
like they would like they would say like
when Cuba gets out he's gonna be a
big-time comic come up because more
[ __ ] managers [ __ ] but I I'll be on
like 12 years said you got to do it on
your own until that I mean there were
hilarious but they had my back you know
it was like a dream for them so it was
uh it's kind of neat when you look you
know you walk into a room I walked into
the carny store I saw Eddie Griffin
walking out it was a tremendous feeling
I didn't know who the [ __ ] you are
listen let me tell you something guys a
real comedian when he's on the hunt you
should know where the television even is
a real comedian when you weren't born or
not I never watched [ __ ] Seinfeld
I don't [ __ ] know what [ __ ] there
is a place you wanna go I don't I never
watch that show never watch yours never
watch is not what I don't know nothing
TV didn't exist to me I didn't come back
into like TV God on my life in 81 and it
didn't show back up till 1999
viii and the girl I was dating said he's
on Newsradio I thought you were a
[ __ ] radio guy
I thought news guy like god you're
broken here this happened in Baghdad
today I didn't [ __ ] know what I
didn't if you're a comic and you're on
the make you're on the [ __ ] roll like
you go out seven nights a week you're at
that three-year mark you should know
what TV you come to me and said you want
Game of Thrones I got look at you wicked
I didn't know no TV my first [ __ ] six
years in comedy I don't know about TV
what [ __ ] TV are you talking about
what movies are you thought what I'm
making you know I didn't understand that
mentality so I never really knew first
TV show I watched and I made a comeback
the television was NYPD book mmm like
Jimmy Smits was dying and that that's
all I remember and Seinfeld was done it
was like the end the Seinfeld people
come up to chew on Seinfeld one of my
humble eight o'clock you [ __ ] done so
made a clog giggle Indian popcorn yeah I
didn't get any TV shows until I was on
one never I never once was last year's
was the show when we were younger but
when I was that you're absolutely right
when I was young and I was struggling in
New York I would go out every night oh
[ __ ] no it's Daniel breather with dvo
mendosa movies I knew some movies I knew
some like family but I didn't know any
[ __ ] TV shows like special they're
like dramas or something like that I
didn't know any of them didn't know
anything I went to maybe two or three
movies that was my escape I would go to
movies that was always my little haven
I'd roll a joint and walk into it my
favorite was like there was a double
feature on the 7 th Street not the black
double feet not the black thing there
was a black movie theater when I went to
see ramble and all that [ __ ] but down
the block was a movie theater they were
doing officer and gentleman fifa hearts
are the-- for heart Steven Bauer and huh
and the dude with the red hair yeah
people they would do like the jerk and
the man with two brains for 250
and I would go in and sit there and just
dream I don't know what I dream about
I dream about being was good I don't
know I would just go to movies like I
would never dream of going to see office
in the gentleman but after I saw that
[ __ ] the first time I was like
god damn Richard Gere ow that was great
that's a great first element you know
it's it's but I never dreamed these
things but walking like I always knew
like I knew from like the six months
account people would say me there's many
sure seeing you like I knew I was
economists or kind of like once I walked
in and I saw dombarris like I wasn't on
a Monday night I came in on a trailer I
got into town at 6:00 I went to Acapulco
for dinner took a shower and right so
Tommy stole my first night I saw wheels
Parisi telling lies I saw Eddie Griffin
with the black dude from the Shogun of
Harlem Tupac what's the time on time on
I was there when he was there I was
there that day on a Monday night is I
had already been there for a few years
when you came yeah yeah I've seen one in
98 yeah 1997 March of January of 97 I
walk in to explore January 29 1987 she
may be a regular February 19 1997 I came
out here with Brewer I think it was 93
to film the pilot and then we came out
in 94 to shoot the show and that's when
I moved here so it was only a couple
months later it was like wintertime or
close to it you know and I I came to the
store immediately so first thing I did
it was more important for me to be like
being a paid regular like when I became
a paid regular because when I first was
on television I was a non paid regular
so I'd have to I would do a TV show all
day and then I'd have to go on at the
end of the show I'd have to wait till
Carlos Mencia would put stockings over
his head he would pull like pantyhose
over his face he had this whole bit
about robbing people like you put
pantyhose over his face and I remember
okay he's pulling out the pantyhose like
I'm going up soon and I would go up
after the show was over after everybody
in their mother
when did comedy and I'd have to get up
and do that but when I became a paid
regular when she finally made me a paid
regular that was more important to me
than anything anything me too
TV show wasn't [ __ ] how did you hear
about it because now with podcast the
stores basically a celebrity it was
before the internet how did you hear
about it because it was Mecca no is
Mecca for Turk comic listening there
when you joined you Jitsu in New York
uh-huh
at a school and [ __ ] Eagle Rock New
York you know that your dream is to go
to what's-his-name hands Oh Gracie oh my
seeing that and that's the mecca HQ you
know I gotta make it to HQ you know I'd
bump into people on the road they go to
me man house HQ you know I could smack
their eyes that's their Mecca to a
comedian that's your Mecca you hear
about the Laugh Factory and you inquire
about the improv but the lat you know
you know people tell you over the years
a man when you get to Vegas make sure
Mitchie shorts
the store was where everybody came from
but for me it was where it the two
greats Kennison and Pryor they all ran
[ __ ] at the store so when I came to the
store like that was hallowed ground like
I remember seeing and sitting in that
room when they when they open bike is on
it's a different show than when the open
mics over and then the pros go up so
like the show will start at whatever
that goes to like whatever I forget what
the numbers are in just seven nine or
six to eight or whatever the [ __ ] it is
but when the real show starts
they shut all the lights off and the
lights that are in the room that uh
they're all like names of the big comics
like Sam Kinison had a neon name and my
Roseanne bars you know and a couple
weird ones like Tamiya was a weird one
it didn't make any sense but there was a
few but she kind of had a little heat on
her way back in the day you know there
was there was a few comics that were on
that wall and I remember like just being
in that room looking up at that wall
going hold
[ __ ] that's that Sam cast is named this
is where he used to go up this was the
[ __ ] stage I had seen these videos I
had seen like VHS tapes him up on this
stage I'm gonna get an off stage on a
Saturday night like doing the best I had
done in the first three months I was
doing Garry Shandling talked to me
knowing if he only knew that I robbed
that blind kids changed would he [ __ ]
still be talking to me do you know I'm
saying like yeah what it felt like to me
when I'd see these people like this is
just it's not a dream come true because
it was never a dream this was always so
far away for a guy like me I didn't this
was all an asset this is all Stanhope
talking to me and going you know you got
to come down there's none in Seattle
that's it you're a fear how long were
you up there in Seattle for 18 months
did you like living up there did the
rain that bum you out you know at the
time I was going through hell in Boulder
so I was just happy to be out of that
mentality that War mentality right and I
didn't really pay attention to it till
you know and you wake up in Seattle it's
the fourth week of rain it does
something you know doesn't do much to me
I'm not gonna hang myself get a shot you
don't feel good there's no Sun you know
for me it would didn't work it's one Sun
the summers are great you know the
waters cold and how Chi and all those
beaches you know Bremerton that waters
[ __ ] real that's the Pacific [ __ ]
that's pinguin Pacific you know that's
coming down it's coming down from there
and as you come down the coast you'll
see the water warms up not by much okay
when you're in our kind you go to
whatever Oregon you know Santa Monica's
[ __ ] Costco
Malibu [ __ ] old you know then you go to
Myrtle Beach it spits water in April
you know seaside is warm is [ __ ] right
now it's hotter than [ __ ] right now yeah
but uh no I enjoy that I enjoyed the
comedy I was so entangled in the comedy
that's what the regular person doesn't
understand that and they do they do
whether you do electrical work or you
body build you Jitsu when we first find
what somebody yeah you get engulfed in
it so this was I went to Seattle when I
was doing comedy my fourth year and I
was in like for the first - I just had a
business card and told people I was a
comedian yeah I mean I got onstage once
a month I do an open mic but the 94 just
hit me like this was it this was all I
had left there was nothing else I was 31
I had been in prison there was a couple
jobs I could do and this was one of them
this fit my lifestyle this I could drink
I could snort blow I get my dick sucked
I have no commitment to nobody no
responsibility you could have a mailbox
somewhere you can have a pager number
somewhere at that time I just want to be
left alone you know I wanted to be
Charles Bronson just do call me doing
comedy but I did all the triple ones I
did those triple runs backwards for over
85 hours a night to feature and gas
comes out and you drive eight hours
between each gate eight hours sometimes
14 sometimes you got to leave right
after the gate just to make Radio the
next day because you'd have to do radio
at 5:00 for the eight o'clock show you
know this is this is combat calmly I
never worked at nothing Joe guys I
always took did something so I found
that there was work involved and that's
what a lot of people [ __ ] do when
they do become 50 I have a friend that
called me two days ago say hello
55 he's still looking for the perfect
job he quits a job every two months you
know because there's work involved it's
just not getting a job now you have to
work people think they go to college and
they get on they said that's or they
whatever you have to [ __ ] work
this guy wants no I can't work for
60,000 e I need on than 30 to start
that's not happening I'm on my friend so
everything else I never worked at
everything when I realized after a month
or two I would say to myself I'm getting
10 bucks an hour
that's 400 a week I saw an Eightball I
can make 400 a day
meanwhile I'm doing what I'm making
cement and putting it on people's trays
and getting abused by the Masons the
[ __ ] my 10 bucks an hour and they're
not teaching me nothing they're not
teaching is [ __ ] you know I'm saying
so Tommy won't like the second year
economy I asked questions and I put it
together in my head what needed to be
done I knew there was a Chihuahua
driving and viola reefa lot of there was
knocking I slept in my car the first
[ __ ] two or three years a commie on
the road is it also that you see other
people doing it and you realize you can
do it like that was yeah when everything
open Mike errs and I saw like people
that were just chipping away at being a
pro I don't like this guy's there's
nothing unique about him he's just
another guy like he's not like some
incredibly talented guy that I couldn't
imagine ever being like I think I could
be like that guy it was like it was it
was attainable enough you know Richard
Jeni always said that he said really
Matt bad comedians are good because they
inspire people to try it cuz they go the
worst I could do is be better than that
guy no you know a good point yeah you
just keep and it takes years it takes he
is to get your voice then you get your
timing and then you get into a place
like the store you start all over again
yeah you get to the store you start all
over again so where the market you came
you were a hot dog and that's what
people can't handle yeah that's what
goes well they come and they've been
[ __ ] killing in Iowa
whoever the [ __ ] they're from and
they're going to comment on their
sandwiched in between Rogan and Nick
DiPaolo
and that's post time [ __ ] it's
Wednesday at 10:45 and you got the 11
o'clock spot and your sandwich and you
you know you know it's it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
and it's your skin and it's your your
pride if you hang out or whatever for a
guy like me
didn't give a [ __ ] I knew it was about
percentages and I knew that the more you
got up there and you worked a little bit
out if the better you get
did you did you ever do stand-up in New
York did you ever learn no no you do in
New York this weekend just we're doing
Gotham that's a great Club great Club in
New York I did New York in 94 what I did
was I got a New York Comedy Club
I go to stand-up New York the dude that
was sick didn't like me at comedy
whatever
the aleutian didn't like in between
driving limos I would stop and get on
stage and I was terrible and I knew I
was terrible but my options where I
would go back and do coke and cry and
look at stand-up comedy by Judy Carter I
look at the comedy newspaper you know
that you should be good just for last
and came out of San Francisco and I
would read the articles like I still
know the best articles I read there were
about Hicks and you know that different
comedy scenes all over the country is
very interesting to read and at the end
they had all the active comedy clubs and
it was pages you know Arizona Arkansas
you know whatever what started would be
with a camera California you know and
you looked a little egg bees and all
these clubs and you had this dream that
someday I might get good enough and I
might be able to play at a piece you
know and then what's her name to the
contest that the county works and Wendy
when did the contest and the winner got
500 bucks and a ticket to Los Angeles to
perform him for Mitzi shore at the
world-famous Comedy Store and there was
his dude Matt woods Matt woods Matt
berry Matt berry so chose Matt woods was
his buddy
and he would work with comics on Tuesday
night take him to his apartment and you
wrote and then you'd go to the open mike
I was always doing the sports benefit I
couldn't get to his apartment so he
didn't really dig me so then I have the
contest that came in second but the
first-place guy had rob side though
and all these comics said he Rob's I
thought so Joey gets the Redeem I got
the 500 button it oh so so he stole some
Seinfeld's just to win the kind of way
they signed read their local scenes it's
funny man it's a funny thing it's like
it's one of the few performance art
forms where you need an audience if you
don't have the audience you can't do it
like you need an audience to create it
like they have to be there otherwise you
don't get if you don't get that feedback
form it's not like you could bring out a
fully developed album like a band could
a band could throw together a fully
developed album and say this is our
first time performing this and then do
their pieces but you you need that
audience and you also need competition
as other comics and that's what some
places just don't have and that that
feeling like when a guy like Lucien
would tell you you suck like look you
really need to work in your act that's
so good it's so important like I hated
hearing it back then like I forget like
he didn't pass me the first time I
performed for him whatever ear was
played in 1990 he just didn't not pass
him he came over to me and said you're
terrible he just did not pass me like
and I thought about it and I go yeah I
know this but I'll be back [ __ ] like
that was I had a li but he had a really
yeah yeah a high-standard guys I wasn't
even in the realm of know of course the
realm of what those guys are important I
was going no no points you to a higher
stage yeah no no it's listen I loved it
I loved it pushes you harder
what about Lewis at catch a rising star
juror performed for him
Louis Miranda no no he had the same
thing going on man yeah Mondays you had
to get a coin yeah and you had to stand
on line no I never went up there never
didn't none of that [ __ ] who I was gonna
get abused at the time to stand up the
one guy who liked me was the one comedy
club and he put me out cuz I brought my
friends and they'd spent money stand up
in New York
give me spots because my friends would
stand money they'd spend you know he'd
get drinks and I get seven minutes here
10 minutes here you know and then I go
to yay old triple win
which is more my style was just a dump
and I would go there the open mic
started at 2 while him one night I went
and John Leguizamo was on stage working
his one-man show and I knew I was on
this when he would do his one-man show
would he do like the whole thing like an
hour like you know I don't I don't
really know one but I walked in and saw
him do 20 minutes and I said he'll be
doing here for a while I had to pick
somebody up in County Airport huh but
that let me know that that was the
system that when you were working on
stuff you went to off-off-broadway
you know saying dad taught me right
there so now I was getting bits and
pieces then I went to Colorado when I
went to Colorado the state said there
was little right now today you come to
me and say I'm a stand-up comic but
there's no place for me to perform I'll
spit in your face you have to you have
to make your own stuff and knowing what
I know now takes you two minutes to go
around I did the comedy head up when I
was in love with Tommy but I couldn't
[ __ ] wait to get onstage and tell
another bad joke you know when you just
can't wait to get on stage I'd have to
go to a poetry reading
you know [ __ ] could tell me my
business pitch nobody that's why I get
busines built I won't stand up listen
you know what go [ __ ] yourself
okay because you're talking to a guy
that went from zero to sixty with it
like I had to learn along the way nobody
guided me like a whole other stand-up
this is what you're doing you have to
make your own it's all getting you think
you're making progress and some of these
steps on your parade then you go back to
the drawing board but every time you go
back to the drawing board you get three
percent better you know when you get a
little bit percent bad and he breaks you
down and hey where'd you get that joke
from be terrible or you know this guy
had called you or you're talking you
know when like when I was doing comedy
in New York I picked up a [ __ ]
horrible habit and once you pick up a
bad habit and stand up it's like when I
was a kid my dad I'd rebound that was a
great rebounder but I always put the
ball on the floor it's a bad habit
grab the ball tippy toe and go right
back up with it once you grab the ball
and bounce it you draw the [ __ ]
people to you why are you doing it
it was a habit that took me years you
know what happened I picked up in New
York
took me five years to get rid of it
talking to the audience that's a big New
York were you from what do you do for a
living you from Jersey and I got into
that habit and that's uh that's a habit
to eliminate writing that's what that
habit does in New York and lemonade's
writing and when you're doing the
stand-ups and those rooms during the
week there's a people you know so you
pick up and that's a habit that one with
me all the way to [ __ ] Seattle and
down hit that leg it came for the comedy
store for a while and I [ __ ] had a
beat it out of me you pick up bad habits
you know you pick up a word that you
won't stop saying something you know and
it just really it's been a great for me
man it saved my [ __ ] life so some
people with DJ saves their life you know
like some people get saved by a DJ for
me I gotta tell you that the more I got
into this the less I got into criminal
activities I wish that this would
overpower the cocaine early in my career
but that monkey was beep Jack was also a
more positive thrill you know you needed
thrills that's what you need imma throw
yeah I'm gonna listen but every comic is
you know I'm trying to write this book
and I wrote these chapters and I was
looking at them and then I go this is
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] and five
chapters haven't spoken one thing about
being a [ __ ] thief let's get this out
of the way like I was a [ __ ] thief
like a [ __ ] klepto
but why'd you have to have in the first
five shot is it about your life nothing
yeah yeah I was just thinking about how
that the play sick of this and how is
this it's just weird
it was I had a thief problem from a
young age like I'm stealing in the first
grade I was stealing teachers of dishes
and selling them to kids with the
answers the books with the answers two
mugs a quarter you know stupid [ __ ]
kids whatever they want the answers but
even as you look at it as that but it
a my habit you couldn't I brought people
with no I would steal your [ __ ] I
would rob ya itches and then once the
cocaine came and fueled it once i my my
insides broke down and stuff it fueled
that habit for a long [ __ ] time so it
was in overpowered that like evening
that I was going on the road and getting
caught shoplifting stealing the tent and
I don't one time on the trip will run
you don't say even overpowered death I
would steal as a form of [ __ ] now
like jinxing me like when things are
going good I would steal something when
the [ __ ] you steal that for so you think
you do on purpose you're sabotaging
yourself oh yeah towards the end towards
the last couple of years of stealing do
you think it was just an impulse thing
like you you want you got a thrill out
of stealing something
no just dog listen we were talking the
other day do you think I like movies is
that what you really think
I got auditions to [ __ ] [ __ ] sir
what do you mean when I go to an
audition is to [ __ ] a [ __ ] up I
hate you shoot them yeah like book in
the movie
I like thrills so you like going and
[ __ ] them up I like all these actors
out there and they're doing breathing
exercises and they're off the side doing
all this [ __ ] this fat [ __ ]
walks in that's a felon and goes watch
this BAM and I'm when I'm walking out I
know it I know when the room just goes
silent and I walked out I stood doing
their breathing exercises and they've
trained that the Actors Studio and I
come home and I get the call so you like
the competition of it all I love all
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] when they you know I
like you know I'm over in Colorado I'd
see these guys at the lifts with [ __ ]
the helmet and the thing went to jacket
pants and the boots in the $3,000 skis
and my brother lost my
ex-brother-in-law's those two Gentiles
they show up with jeans on a [ __ ]
construction shirt and smoke everybody
and they go you know I like those guys
that then I dress like right there with
thee breakfast and the guy came in by
himself and riding the bike with the
cleats on the helmet
while the drunk you win a race let it go
already
like I never wanted like I don't know it
was just I loved auditioning so we're
thrilled
well this is a weird row for me I love
[ __ ] people up but that came from
burglarize I loved it when I met a drug
dealer and I went to his house and he
thought it was cool
he'd put a gun and he'd say to me yeah
you know this and this I got two kilos
in the house
and two days later I just wake up in the
middle of mango I'm robbing that
[ __ ]
watching me watch my heat and I let's
say it was this off as I plant across
the street but for three days I'd figure
out how to get in for this [ __ ]
office and he had the coke in hand with
all his surgery and all his pit bulls
and all his toughness I figured out a
way how to climb through that [ __ ]
window
and come in and rob his coke and leave I
loved it I loved it and I loved him
walking in somebody [ __ ] robbed me
and me and my buddies are there sitting
there go come on what the [ __ ] happened
somebody came in broken to my one which
is [ __ ] Howlin inside
I loved all that [ __ ] I love my heart
beating I loved the dog for so long that
I know I couldn't do it I couldn't do it
for a lifestyle you can't do it for a
[ __ ] lifestyle you know why did you
figure that out after you didn't been in
jail yeah after you go to jail you talk
to all those people you know that the
odds are always against you but the
problem is when people go to jail and
they team up with other people
they're like minded they become stronger
criminals they learn more things now you
tell me how you got caught Lee tells me
he got caught and I tell you how you got
caught we figured out
my god so next time we do traveler's
check so you don't you be following me
institutional it's an institutionalize
so that's it it makes you you become a
better [ __ ] criminal and you go in
there you know once I got out of there I
knew I saw a lot of people that didn't
belong there but I knew people in there
that should have been shot they
shouldn't even warehouse them they
should just be shot because they never
there's no such thing as rehabilitation
these people can't get out to do another
[ __ ] crime again but then there's the
guy that went to out to a party drank a
big I'm a car and killed somebody on a
red light you know and he goes to jail
for six years from the voluntary
manslaughter it was just a [ __ ] bad
place at the wrong time do you follow me
there's two types of criminals yeah you
[ __ ] up right this other guy is a
[ __ ] animal you know so it's just but
that's it definitely cured me I think
the calm me definitely the more I get
involved with it and it wasn't even if
the success because the first success I
ever had in comedy was becoming a
regular to commish but you're absolutely
right to me that was the end-all be-all
that was the [ __ ] Club well you just saw
a very impulsive guy in that that
impulsiveness a lot of it comes from
troubled childhoods comes from an
absence of love you know avoid you know
what whatever the cause of it is you you
were impulsive sort of a troubled guy
and so I think that the thrill did you
got those wild thrills that you got from
stealing or from you know robbing a drug
dealer you just figured out a way to
replace up and that but the
impulsiveness is what leads to all the
weird things that you wound up doing the
drug thing like all the different things
you want to do and where you you
sabotage yourself and a lot of it is
just this it's the inability to maintain
normalcy the inability to stay on a
steady path you're always constantly
used to things failing on you and so to
alleviate the disappointment you'll fail
on yourself on myself I would yeah
I did that to everybody did everybody
does that it's uh it's just something
that I I did a little less because of
the fighting because of the martial arts
background cuz you couldn't do that in
fighting the stakes were too high it's
too dangerous you need to see too many
people get kicked in the head so when
you would go in there man you had to go
in there that was you had the only way
to really compete was you had to figure
out how to just let it all go and just
turn into like an animal you got to go
wild you know you can't have any like
once it starts you can't act with fear
you have to be completely Zen and you
got to be able to get wild and so he
couldn't sabotage yourself like you
couldn't not Train you couldn't get
drunk before you would fight and be
hungover when you showed up to weigh in
you couldn't do any of those things
those were too scary so that saved me in
a lot of ways from being the type of
impulsiveness that I had that led me be
a stand-up comedy a stand-up comedian
would have manifested itself in drugs or
crime or sometimes it would have
definitely would have because I didn't
fit in and I'd always felt like a loser
so I would have done something
disastrous and I ever had any success in
anything in life so I always assumed
that I was never going to have any
success so if I ever started having any
success I'd immediately sabotage it
immediately I know I would but martial
arts I couldn't do that
and I also couldn't do it because my
instructor because I didn't grow up with
my father my instructor took the place
of my father as like a high model a high
role model of a man you know martial
arts champion who was like well
respected throughout the country he took
the place like this authoritarian place
and my life completely changed you know
became completely like rigid and
disciplined so because of that I like
carrying that over allowed me to not
sabotage my comedy career too much you
know but I everybody does it you know
everybody just has moments where just
for whatever reason you do the wrong
thing or you say the wrong thing I think
the wrong thing and a lot of times you
don't even realize while you're doing
until you get older yeah if you watch
old mythologic when they gave him the
shot at the Hollywood Bowl for the gay
better
and he went up there and [ __ ] started
going on like where the [ __ ] were you
[ __ ] when I needed your mother
I had they went to his house the next
day said what the [ __ ] happened Richard
Oh what the [ __ ] is why were you how can
you do that I mean and comics you know
our minds work [ __ ] crazy you know
our minds it's it's it's just to figure
out how to get out of your own way yeah
it scares me sometimes if I can scares
me man
yeah well four huge extra for you extra
because for the longest time when I knew
you you had the drug problem and that
was one of the things that you were very
close to my friend Johnny very similar
cuz johnny was another guy who was a
brilliant guy who was a street guy who
was a pool hustler and when I met him he
was homeless he was sleeping in pool
halls he would go to Chelsea billiards
there's a 24-hour pool hall he would
sleep under the table I mean a lot of
guys did that there's a few guys did
that and they would hustle they'd have
one guy that got arrested there would
run a three-card Monte I mean it was
like to have the shell game that they
would run I mean everybody's figured out
a way to make money other than working a
regular job and they were all druggies
all of them everyone was a junkie
almost everyone the guys who weren't
with the guys feel like strict
ironically when you hear this story one
of the guy who wasn't who was on the
straight and narrow I won't say his name
out of respect cuz he died recently and
he's a pretty famous player he was mr.
clean and and he would always looked
down upon everybody until he had a back
injury and the back injury they put him
on those [ __ ] pills and he was gone
he started smoking cigarettes
he started it started gaining weight he
like he became this pill popper and my
friend said the last time saw before he
died he died young the last time he saw
me fell asleep and a [ __ ] plate of
food just punk look at a movie plopped
his face into mashed potatoes and mashed
potatoes are stuck to his eyebrows and
his nose he's fell asleep from the
heroin from the pills from the
oxycottons just plop tubes and this was
a guy that when my friend Johnny was a
junkie and when all these guys the pool
halls were drunk you
guy wouldn't even drink he was and he
was a pro I mean he was well respected
he was in his 20s back then and he was
you know top top 15 top 30 in the
country he was a high level guy when you
get to that level like top 30 pool
players in the country on any given
night one guy can [ __ ] hit a stride
and beat anybody you know and he he was
a good dude man that was a sad thing to
see I've seen a few guys like that that
we're on the street now there's nothing
wrong with them and then they've gone
those goddamn [ __ ] pain pills and for
him it was a back thing that's probably
related to pool because he didn't
exercise didn't lift weights and keep
you like the thing about pool is you put
a lot of stress on you like your your
your head is up and your body's bent and
you're playing sometimes for like you
know eight [ __ ] nine hours a day it's
not uncommon to play every day when
you're a high level pool player so your
back is going through a lot of stress
and pressure and almost none of those
guys did yoga almost none of those guys
lift weights and some of them would
develop back problems this [ __ ] dude
got a back problem and then I think he
actually even got in a car accident - so
we've got more [ __ ] up and they
started with the pills
it's amazing the mind of the hustler
because the other day about two weeks
ago you got up early and you no matter
what time I get up Diaz is already and
that's if you dare rule of that
mentality that's the house everything
you're hustling with everyday hustle
then when I wake up under that table at
6 o'clock and I don't know how I got
here
you know I was to choose if I wake if I
was to wake up on that couch tomorrow at
6 to beat I would know I doubt it I wake
up there probably be some powder on the
table it'd be a little bit left to be a
half a beer and you go to the bathroom
and then you come back and you think
about what happened last night you look
at your phone you go through your
pockets and you got three dollars in
your [ __ ] starving and that's when
the Hustle starts my friend right there
though it starts you already got a guy
who you go see to give you two eggs and
bacon and a [ __ ] piece of toast and
put it on a tab till five o'clock so you
got till 5:00
make it happen gotta brush your teeth
call me ain't gonna pool or whatever
[ __ ] miss something there and you
never know could be pool could be some
guy who robbed a box off UPS and there
were wrenches on there and the only go
summons it's [ __ ] mind-boggling but
tell how mind-boggling it was when I
moved to Colorado first left that area
in New Jersey in 83 I slept for three
weeks straight
wasn't the acclamation that was always
it was just my mind the stress level
went from here to here you know I just
[ __ ] fell apart that was it it's a the
mind of a hustler is just a it's a lot
of grinding [ __ ] yoga okay
some guys sittin at 6:00 the morning
going you know what I need I need a
little downward dog before I take some
real a boy this guy who was one of the
guys that used to go to the pool hall
was just disgusting pervert he was
disgusting and he played some pretty
decent pool but he was he was what they
call scary ass like you wouldn't you
would never make a bet unless he was
absolutely sure he could win so that
everyone was always trying to con
everyone else like even the hustlers
they would try to hustle each other they
talk [ __ ] to each other [ __ ] I'll give
you the eight nine and the breakstep the
[ __ ] up right now I'll give you two to
one on the money they said like they'd
make these crazy propositions with each
other if they didn't get in the action
and this one guy was like the most scary
you wouldn't wouldn't play anybody
unless he had just everything locked
down but he would play like regular
people were coming off the street he
would try to get like he looked like
he's a shape he looked like a degenerate
he looked like like he was falling apart
but he was a super [ __ ] creepy
pervert and he would pay old ladies like
old homeless ladies to jerk off in their
face he would give them like he would
give them like five dollars or ten
dollars and you know like the lady he
was talking about like she was saying I
am a grandmother I can't believe you're
doing this he'd go shot
calm in her face and she's an old
homeless lady
oh I go you're jerking off in an old
homeless lady's face he's like I'd love
it I love it crying plays coming on her
face I'm a grandmother I'll cry the
bathroom wasn't that [ __ ] goo off
their face they all cried like a [ __ ]
65 seven year old lady he's jerking off
in her face and she's homeless a 65 year
old homeless lady and he's coming in her
face for five bucks you think about it
when you somebody just comes in your
face and you're in the bathroom why's it
up what are you thinking about your life
he really loves me I mean what the [ __ ]
are you thinking well some girls like it
yes some girls like it when you come in
their face but they're generally young
it's fun and it's wild they're not 65
year old homeless grandmas when you're
you when you really are getting off I
jerked off on some poor starving old
lady's face like those are the type of
people that you'll find or you used to
find in New York they don't have them
anymore they don't I think they have a
couple 24-hour joints in New York but
everything closes now everything has a
closing time whether it's 2:00 or 4:00
there was a bunch of pool halls a bunch
in Manhattan when I was around it was
still nothing compared to the turn of
the century at the turn of the century
in 1900 there was a thousand pool halls
in New York City 1,000 pull holes in New
York City that was the the bachelor
lifestyle these guys they didn't want to
[ __ ] the day this was like during
like the area of the depression like the
1920s especially they didn't want to
have to take care of a [ __ ] family
and a wife it was hard enough just rough
scrabble trying to feed yourself like
what I want to have a [ __ ] wife and a
kid and have to go out there and and
figure out a way to feed them and have
them [ __ ] starving like I was
starving when I was growing up like so
many people were starving like that that
they were scared and this bachelor
lifestyle kind of grew out
that also it was fun they were playing
cards and shooting craps and getting
arrested and pool halls were
automatically associated with derelicts
and degenerates in fact the game pool is
not even called pool
it's called pocket billiards pool is a
term for throwing all your money in
pooling your money for games cuz
everybody would gantt whether it would
throw in like you very rarely bet your
own money like guys would like to go who
wants in on this I could beat this
[ __ ] let's let's [ __ ] make
some money and that's how these guys
they were like a lot of it they were
feeding off of each other and they would
the thousand pool hall so you traveling
all over the [ __ ] city and that was
the bachelor lifestyle for these guys
that pool hall lifestyle that's why I
was always associated with the glorious
result of a misspent youth like
everybody who was a good pool player
like to this day that's like that weird
it's a weird thing like if a guy's good
at badminton guess what nobody gives a
[ __ ] you know but if if a chick walks
into a pool hall and starts chalking up
the queue and says you guys wanna bet
some money on this like oh shake and she
[ __ ] play pool [ __ ] if this [ __ ]
beats me at pool that's like she's
stealing your manhood a chick can beat
you at miss pac-man and nobody gives a
[ __ ] okay but if a chick breaks and runs
out on you for a hundred bucks she's
like oh my god I just lost it game of
pool to a chick because it was a totally
male bachelor lifestyle sort of a
pastime for like the longest time that's
what I loved about it man when I first
came to New York and I was applied I
started playing in Boston that's when I
first started playing but not seriously
until I hurt my ACL I tore my ACL on my
knee and I didn't have insurance yet so
I had to wait a while and faked an
injury and then get my insurance and
half wait until after set in allegedly
this is all fiction so anyway I started
playing pool with my friend John and who
was a stand-up comic John Tobin he's a
radio personality now in New York and we
started playing pool at this place call
the executive billiards and then I met
the owner there and then I was I didn't
not play at all I was just learning and
then I met Johnny he was trying to
hustle me that's how I met him
I was like who's this [ __ ]
trying to pretend he doesn't know how to
play pool like it was where he was we
were laughing like while he was trying
to talk me into a game you know like I
go I'm not good like he goes don't worry
about we could figure out a way to make
a game like what does that mean make a
game what does that mean
hey goes we'll figure out a way to make
it even I go the Snowy even I go you're
good and I'm not good so how's it ever
gonna be even he starts laughing and
we're laughing but I got to see these
guys that were all just hanging out
there all the time they would get off
work and they would rush over there
there was deli Steve they would call him
deli Steve because he worked at the deli
there was Ray the fireman Ray the
fireman he would they would do 24 hour
shifts at the fireplace
so he would do his 24 hour shifts you
cook over there hang out with the guys
and then he would come in and when the
shifts Rovers coming to the pool hall
you no need to hang out you know you
could show up but executive buildings
and knock on a door at 4 o'clock in the
morning and if the lights were on
there's guys in the gamblin they just
locked the door after closing time we'd
stay open till dawn then we go to star
diner and have [ __ ] breakfast I mean
it was fun it was all fun so what I had
this girlfriend I had a serious
girlfriend for a while one time she said
you know she gave me an ultimatum she's
like it's either me or pool I go rack
him up so I said I said rack them up I
go that place is fun I nobody complains
like yeah you're pretty and you're fun
to be around you're nice and uh-huh I
like having sex with you all those
things are true but you're not taking me
away from the pool hall the pool hall
was fun it was all men like you would go
then everyone was laughing the place
would be thick with cigarette smoke I
didn't give a [ __ ] you'd go in there and
everybody would be like you know it was
just a bunch of animals they didn't have
to show up with a suit and tie on they
didn't have to be stuck in a [ __ ]
cubicle they didn't have to file the
rules the human resource set up for the
company they got to be themselves they
got to be themselves in a world that
doesn't let you be yourself in a world
that doesn't let you swear a world that
doesn't want you on pills
you could buy pills from everybody there
was this guy Jeff Jeff I had my knee
operated on so they gave me percocets
I took one I was like [ __ ] these things
they're terrible I sold them the Jeff
and Jeff was selling them in the pool
you could get anything in that place
this is the first time I ever saw a guy
do heroin first time ever saw a guy do
heroin is this guy used to call him
water dog his name was he had a bunch of
nicknames water dog buffalo bill had a
couple different nicknames I don't even
remember his real name but he would go
into the bathroom and and shoot up and
they would come out and just sit on a
stool like this for 30 minutes just sit
there like with his mouth open his hands
down and then screw his cue together
step over the table and couldn't [ __ ]
miss there was a trick table they had
this table table one and it was what's
called double shimmed which means like a
regular tables five-inch pockets of gold
crowns five inches this table was under
four inches it's a tiny little hole and
it was a trick table in that like the
guy who did the shim job was a shitty
[ __ ] table mechanic so if you hit the
point at all coming in it would
literally bounce the ball out of the
hole you hit it perfectly to get it in
there and he's firing balls into this
table he couldn't miss he couldn't miss
the heroin had completely removed his
nerves and he would say that he just saw
the table different he would just see
the table takes you in ambitions like
when I said when you get really high in
the night before and you go do something
takes you in a vision you don't even
think about what you think about before
and he's playing for big money yeah he
was playing for like $10,000 once he was
playing this guy and it was huge
everybody came from all over the place
guys guys drove up from Connecticut to
see this match and he was stuck I was so
[ __ ] mad because he had went into the
bathroom and did his junk and he came
back out sat down for 30 minutes and
then couldn't miss and couldn't miss
just running out on him and then to
screaming at each other and the guy the
the heroin guy Buffalo Bill the dudes
screaming I'm Scott George the Greek
screaming at him and he's looking at
George like this nothing didn't register
didn't register that he was in danger
didn't register that he should scream
back didn't he's like we plan we're
gonna keep playing like he did anything
I guess it's over I guess this is over
he starts unscrewing it screw a [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] got no heart get back on
that [ __ ] table and you get back on
the table you wouldn't miss again for
five hours
but I saw like world-class pool from a
guy that it just for 30 minutes at day
like this it really is [ __ ] nice what
the place was glorious man I really need
to write a book about the the glory days
of executive billions because it's like
a disco now they have a Facebook page
you go to the Facebook page it's in
White Plains New York the Facebook page
it's like girls twerking and a music
plane and lights are flash and I'm like
what is this this was like a great pool
hall I still can't get over the balls it
would take to go to like a 70 year old
grandma who's homeless hey jerk let me
come in your face oh he was a dirty
person he was oh my god this guy was
such a dirtbag he was such a dirtbag and
he was essentially homeless too they
would either be homeless or they would
get these these they would rent beds and
these flop houses like they would it was
like a place where like you know they
have little tiny rooms and they had a
bed and you would you know it you'd all
share like a group toilet so you
wouldn't really be homeless but you
might as you just had a place to sleep
and then get the [ __ ] out of there's no
kitchen is all your money went to pool
while most of it was junk you know most
of them were junkies there wasn't
see their money didn't really go to pool
you know like that that wasn't like the
if they would play a lot of times like
they could get some free table time from
some of the rooms if they knew guys you
know they could play for the time like
for practice and there was like cheap
practice time wasn't that expensive to
play pool it was the money was all going
to drugs that was really weird like the
big big of Johnny scored if he scored
you would vanish he would vanish you
know and sometimes it just sometimes you
didn't know if you were gonna see him
again because he would go to like this
sketchiest parts of Spanish Harlem to
score blow or to score he score crack
and you know then it towards II Anna
became heroine and when it became a
heroine that's when he came to visit me
once
came to visit me once when I was doing
news radio it's like one of the last
times I got a chance to see him and he
was detoxing he came out his idea was he
was gonna come out visit me and when he
was out he was gonna stay with me for
like a week and he would just clean up
during that time but he was just every
day was like he had the flu just shaking
lying in bed and just by the time like
six seven days use himself again
it was just the saddest [ __ ] thing to
say this guy just trying to kick it it
was just in his it was in his
bloodstream yeah no it said that that in
those [ __ ] pills to my friend just
detox on pills same thing it's the same
exact thing - same exact thing it's the
same exact mechanism it's the same exact
drug it's an opiate they're the hardest
to kick after the surgery I think I took
six of those things did you did you
worry about taking them no my [ __ ]
dollars yeah but did you worry that you
would like somehow or another decide
that like you would start doing drugs
again not just you're in a different
place in your life now yeah you know
what you've also the thing that I've
noticed about you over the last couple
of years that's really changed in like
the last like three or four years it's
really from once you start doing
podcasts and people got a chance to see
the real you and then once people saw
the real you you would go on stage like
we started doing shows and you would go
on stage and people would go [ __ ]
crazy they would start cheering and it
was a different thing I was like they
knew you now so you could just be
yourself and the amount of love that you
would get you get so much love
everywhere we went I saw it like
changing your perceptions of yourself
you know I saw it cuz like we would do
shows way back in the day where you know
they didn't know you were and I you know
you would go on stage and those days I
didn't even bring you up I didn't like
to do the mic on the side like the DJ
would do it or whatever yeah yeah you
had a fight for your life these [ __ ]
people are not there to see you they did
see me you got a you got a so and it's
just you know it's tricky that's a
tricky tricky thing sometimes this
podcast has changed me
of course the podcast that we do has
changed because I gotta live up to what
the [ __ ] I'm talking I'm not I can't
talk about picking up a piece of paper
and I'm not picking up I can't talk
about you gotta go outside your comfort
zone
I joined jujitsu I joined you Jitsu to
show people that you could do whatever
[ __ ] you want they can't say no to you
and I go every day as hard as it isn't
people hit me up every day
bro thank you for talking me into going
now jujitsu
you know the drugs that I couldn't even
a man I couldn't even
yeah cuz you round up you're in a
positive place you're on a good path
nobody's know anything about me when I
say it's over it's over yeah I did that
last line of blow that night that was it
for me that was it that was it that was
a big hurdle
every day that I got off it it made me
stronger and it made me [ __ ] though I
don't want to do that number I didn't
want to be there no more if it's a shame
it was a big time period of my life you
know but now I'm trying to you know
redeem it and I'm just trying to you
know when I do this podcast whether it's
you or Woodley and I talk this [ __ ] I
talk I gotta walk it now well I just
can't talk [ __ ] no I'm lying now from my
words yeah yeah I opened myself up at
the same time I'm letting people know
you know what I'm an ex-felon I didn't
go to [ __ ] I didn't have fancy
parents I didn't come out here with a
credit card you do what the [ __ ] you
want you know you could keep thinking
about it what's drop your balls on and
go for it that's it you did it we had to
do it I had those fun of somebody that
said they went back to Connecticut for a
week to see their parents their family
and they couldn't believe how different
they were from that he's only been here
for four years you Jessica and he goes I
can't believe how different they are I'm
I told you every time you go home you go
there less and less yeah you go home now
yelling I'm gonna Boston but no [ __ ]
10 days I can't go to Jersey field ten
days you go less and less because you
see more and he was telling me how he
can't believe that nobody his family has
ever been out of the county
never mind the state the [ __ ] County
you know they all live they all live six
miles from the family when the father
they go to the house and they can't talk
it's a gif ID they watch sports and
nobody talks to themselves they don't
talk until the father ask a question
then they all answer them then it goes
to silence he goes forget the dinner
table they don't laugh at the dinner
table you don't even know I was braised
in that [ __ ] house but you need to
step out of things to see him and the
more you're out of them you keep seeing
I mean seeing
very funny last week somebody sent me
the Tiago Silva tape you know many
nights I walk around cocaine with a gun
in my hair we think he's special
you think the agile Salvage well he was
looking for a guy too and he was over
her I was looking for cops and shoes
under the bed shoes under picking up
things behind the flag you know when I
go into a hotel room in the old days
first thing I did was shake down the
room look at cabinets one before I did
the coke in the hotel room at night I
would open up the wine cabinets in the
soda machine and make sure there's no
cameras in the [ __ ] room you know
that's your paranoia mind that's the
cocaine working so when I saw that
[ __ ] tape my stomach went into or not
you know many nights I would do a line
of coke and walk walk around the room
with the [ __ ] razor blade and the
mirror right here and the gun the other
thing come out I'll [ __ ] shoot you
come out you [ __ ] you know how
scary that is and people would say what
are you doing nothing no you're just
looking out of [ __ ] window Joey
welcome Shh
I thought I saw a fire down the corner
and you go back and you do it and you
when you walk to the table to do a line
you walk backwards so the whole time you
got your I think one time I was just
doing coke for years and my friends came
out to visit me in Boulder Colorado and
I was about how is our [ __ ] federal
probation they would come to my house
and I'll piss me and I wouldn't open the
door the one day I didn't open the door
I told this [ __ ] I ain't going
down you know I didn't tell him that I
just heard upstairs he kept saying I
know you're in there forget I went to a
hotel with these guys and the hotel they
start playing cards and all you bring
the pipe they ask the other guy on my
pipe you guys smoking weed like nah dawg
crack I'm like leather sell I never
smoked rat I'm like crack crack wait
Harlem crack like that like you don't
black people jumping up and now
yeah that type of cracker I know [ __ ]
give me a hit I thought I did a hit and
I was in the shower behind the curtain
like it was horrible they were laugh
when I come out I'm I know there's
somebody on top of that roof he's a
[ __ ] sniper you know what I saw at
the house overcame it disturbed me so
much my heart goes out to him I couldn't
judge it cuz I've been there what's
crazy is he got reinstated in the UFC
and they got launched and then they
found this tape and you know again they
don't give up the [ __ ] ex-wife sent
the tape in she's like there's something
you might want to think oh yeah yeah you
know I mean that this [ __ ] seems like
she was a crazy [ __ ] and
obviously that's the worst when I'm
telling you I know something you're
telling me you're crazy I don't say she
hopes up a Popovich in [ __ ] Saudi
Arabia so did him same dog he wasn't
that [ __ ] crazy he was going to her
house with a gun because he knew that
[ __ ] was a dirty [ __ ] yeah okay that's
what he was doing with a [ __ ] gun
nobody goes to [ __ ] home to mrs.
Rogan with a gun and walked around the
house order your girlfriend and walks
around the house were you looking I
don't know if they were split up I think
they might have been already split up
when this was going on I think you've
just cooked up and being crazy I don't
think he was with her oh my god he was
like yeah he was Jack did you what
happen Evangeline he got suspended for
life for life
no no he's like barred from fighting for
life he's not even allowed in Las Vegas
like prohibited prohibited they banned
it with all this he lives in LA I don't
know what happened that's goofin but
gave him a $75,000 fine for running
which he went I was gonna pay him unless
they put a judge my was it well I think
they they owned like a giant chunk I
mean that I don't know if he even got
his purse
well first I mean that's true he didn't
even have the phone like he did not but
he had a fight scheduled like so he
didn't get any of it
no no so he wasn't even under contract
yet so the the real question is do they
have the jurisdiction to actually test
him since he wasn't under contract
he wasn't licensed so he didn't he
hadn't applied for a license yet so
although he had
for fight with Chael Sonnen they signed
like they were they were they were set
he hadn't applied for his license yet
and until he applies for his license
they don't really technically have the
jurisdiction to test him because he's
not applying for a license you can't
just show up in my house and say hey I
want to test your pee but I quit I don't
even work for UPS yet you know like you
can't
once he once he signs on and so that's
what his attorneys claiming which is
very interesting
I just think though the penalty is way
over the top like it's one thing if you
want to tell the guy he's suspended for
a year like pretend as if you caught him
for steroids
you know caught say it like you caught
what would you do if you caught him if
you if you got caught it was the first
time being caught it would be nine
months suspension so instead of doing
that they decide to prohibit him from
fighting for a [ __ ] life
a whole life like he can't be 80 and
apply for a license from running away
from one drug test I think that's
ridiculous
it was time to send the message the
fighters a lot of Fighters yeah but you
can't you can't do it like that you're
sending a message that you have ultimate
power and you're unreasonable that's not
reasonable it's one thing if they they
said hey we're gonna suspend it for two
years like Chael Sonnen he got suspended
for two years this last one two years
when you're thirty I think jail is 36 37
somewhere around there that's big that's
big those are two years when you're at
the end of your prime anyway I mean you
know even in your in a weight class like
a 185 205 pound weight class when you
get to be like 35 36 it's pretty much
the tail end of your career heavy
weights have a little bit longer like
they they generally mature later and can
compete at a higher level later lighter
weight guys like fly weights they
they're their careers end even earlier
than that 35 is the high end for like a
flyweight but to take away a guy's two
years is big but to say you can never
fight again ever
because you ran a test he ran from a
test
he [ __ ] up he definitely [ __ ] up but
but you can't set that's so
unprecedented and it's so crazy I coulda
mean if they said they would gonna
suspend it for two years man that's
harsh as [ __ ] but it's been a bad month
for sports yeah it has it's been a bad
month for sports and you know what yeah
but there's a big difference between a
guy running from a drug test and a guy
beating the [ __ ] out of his kid with a
stick or knocking his girlfriend out in
an elevator like those are those are
different things that's like some evil
[ __ ] what a lot is going on and this is
what nobody likes to talk about but a
lot is going on is that these guys have
been juking the system for a long time
there's a bunch of them that had been
juking the system when it comes to
performance-enhancing drugs and jail
jail was the tip of the iceberg when he
got popped it sent a real message to
everybody like they're testing
everything now and then a lot of other
guys got popped
Bogg latina off got popped for EPO a lot
of guys are getting popped left and
right Kevin Casey King Kevin Casey and
he got a pop for steroids after his
fight they got rid of him you know
there's a lot of guys that are getting
popped left and right and what we're
finding out is that a lot of these folks
would get clean like right before a
fight but in between fights if you just
catch them just show up at their house
go come here man
penis cut for him real quick I need some
of your blood they're all there's a good
percentage of them that are hot can you
believe vandala what's his name right
now he must be [ __ ] happy as [ __ ]
Vitor he's probably taking a plane to
China with a mascot
shooting [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ] he's
like this the best day of my [ __ ]
life
I caught a breather well he's that's a
terrible situation because it's he's
like 36 37 years old and he was on
testosterone for the last few years so
his natural testosterone is completely
dropped down to a very very low level
and he's got to figure out how to fire
that back up it's actually very good for
him that the fight is in February as
opposed to closer to the time when they
get off the testosterone because it
gives his body more time to fire up and
if he can go back to Brazil perhaps he
can engage certain activities that could
perhaps benefit him to re-engage his
testosterone system see that's the other
thing they don't let these guys take
drugs that bodybuilders take when they
get off steroids that have been proven
to restart your your system okay well I
don't even think it would be it's not
like a performance-enhancing drug effect
it's a normalcy effect there's like
stuff called clomid and these things are
what they call estrogen suppressors so
it's it's it suppresses the level of
estrogen you have which raises the level
of testosterone apparently in some way I
don't understand the mechanism but a lot
of bodybuilders when they get off of
steroids they will take this stuff and
this is one of the things that jail was
on like because they made them get off
the [ __ ] testosterone the guy was on
testosterone for years you make him get
off of it and all of a sudden they feel
like [ __ ] they're tired they can barely
get through a workout they don't have
any pep in their step they go no pop it
dick doesn't work and the only way to
get your system fired back up again is
to wait either wait time do a lot of
like high intensity exercises to try to
kick it back in and for everybody the
amount of time it takes to kick it back
in is different so for Vitor to get it a
few extra months like what is it now
we're in September they're doing it in
what February so they said it was so
think about that he's got October
November December January and then in
February so he's got another five months
that's good for him no but the fight was
one next week December yeah so he only
got two months yeah yeah you got too
much more but he's got five months from
now from from now he's got enough time
till I give his body like another he's
not a [ __ ] plan buddy like this right
Robin that [ __ ] juice it's like me
would have a ball in my pocket well
those stage did want to clean that sport
up man they want to clean that sport up
and that's the way to do it the way to
clean it up is to randomize the drug
testing and to do like the most
stringent level
testing that's imaginable and that's
what they're doing right now each test
costs $40,000 every time they test these
guys across $40,000 it's super expensive
and it's coming out of the UFC's pocket
and they're doing it because look they
can't keep running into these situations
where guys get popped hot if these
athletic commission tests because it
makes the sport look terrible and it
devalues the brand if you have a sport
and all of your top champions are all on
steroids and everybody knows you're on
steroids in a lot of people's eyes it
devalues the sport and it can it can if
guys keep getting caught and they keep
testing positive and it just it remains
a trend for a long period of time you
don't you don't set a new standard and
let everybody know like look this is
what it is you guys can't be on drugs if
you're on drugs they're going to ban you
they're gonna kick you off the [ __ ]
sport they're gonna make sure that you
lose a significant percentage of your
purse then they're gonna ban you for a
year where you can't make it a living
doing doing your sport for like a
[ __ ] year so stop it if they didn't
do that if guy it becomes a mockery and
it becomes a mockery it actually D
values the sport in a lot of people's
lives and it could be it could be
detrimental to the like the bottom line
of a business and that's the difference
between like guys like Lorenzo Fertitta
he runs casinos they know how to make
money they know where money is not being
made correct and they know what this is
oh they like it's like playing a game of
poker like you know what your hand is
and you know most likely with his hand
is you have an idea and you know this is
not gonna work out well unless we do
something here like I'm gonna fold and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna wait
until I have a good hand and then I'm a
bet like you're playing in advance
you're looking at the future and if
they're looking at the future they go
okay let's look what's going on here
these guys keep getting caught and when
they get caught a lot of these guys are
saying everyone's on it a lot of these
guys are saying Vitor said that he's
like 90% of these guys used when they're
in camp
that's what Vitor said he would know
better than any of us so a Vitor saying
something like that he's not known as a
liar he's saying something like that you
got to think there might be something to
it and if you want to nip that [ __ ] in
the bud there's only one [ __ ] way you
got to randomly test these dudes you got
to show up knock knock
I guess we are where the guy wants your
blood and we're gonna have a chain of
custody of this blood and take it on a
[ __ ] plane to Baltimore where there's
some super-secret national security
agency lab that doesn't [ __ ] anything up
and we're gonna test everything that you
you have in your blood we're gonna find
out if you have artificial testosterone
we're gonna find out if you taking human
growth hormone if you're on
EPO if you're on birth control pills
what are the [ __ ] you're on we're gonna
find out what you're on we're gonna know
exactly what you're all about
so that's a giant wake-up call to all
these fighters and we might have to
reevaluate like what guys are capable of
you know it's one of the things that
Dolce said I had him on the podcast the
other day we were talking about this
then I think that we have a elevated
expectation of what guys can do and a
lot of is based on like the juiced-up
days you know like the juiced-up days of
pride my favorite juice to the tits like
Wanderlei Silva in his prime was you
know he was just a muscle a giant veiny
muscle of destruction just smashing
guy's knees and [ __ ] gags and soccer
kicks and stomps he head-butted guy
Metzger [ __ ] head-butted him before
he knocked him out he hit him with a
combination head-butted them and then
right handed him and not to know how I
mean he had fought knocked at him
knocked him out he had fought all these
valley to know fights and a lot of those
fights Valley tutos anything goes that's
what I mean he fought those bare-knuckle
fighter brazil war that headbutts were
legal so there's many videos of him
head-butting guys standing up it's
[ __ ] cracking him with head buds so
when he fought guy Metzger give a
headbutt just came in handy like oh I
know how to do this prank crack just
crazy fights and who knows what kind of
chemicals those gathered wrong I'll get
the chemicals Lisa
what kind of chemicals genome whatever
brownie and gammy Jesus Christ you could
barely see look at his eyes this is
going deep oh my this is what made Tom
Segura take a Boober home this is this
game like double what he is uses like a
carrot your eyes are your caricature I
know you're squeezing them shut this is
like you're like you're playing a
character this is the the high guy who
can't see no those brownies are
you ain't [ __ ] around they go yeah I
take em I'll live these aren't [ __ ]
around either man these P now you know
those guys I told the storing you dummy
bear guy I connected with these guys
because of your podcast uh you know how
how that cousin is the story I told the
guy that was throwing the bales of coke
off the plane so I told the story they
came to flappers the fact I'm gonna see
I'm gonna see a tweety that's Thursday
the guy who threw the bales off the
[ __ ] plane the game 50 who is coming
up with the [ __ ] contest of flappers
did you see this latest contest about
doing dead comedians acts on Halloween
they do doing a show a special show
well they do a tribute where they are
different comedians will do dead
comedians acts on Halloween
leave those [ __ ] Christians all over
they're mine they're Christians they're
not really pisses me off but in their
thieves that's a really pisses they're
thieves
yeah then will you 50% of the door and
then do away tickets about that but for
they're probably starving
they're probably barely staying open
know for years they don't get off times
in [ __ ] 20 comedy shows go on a
nightmare go look at their web page okay
how much they paper in the room though
there's getting all the liquor I don't
know I don't know what their papers but
I know that they doing something right
over there cuz they kept open for four
[ __ ] years I keep wanting to go there
but Bob at the [ __ ] ice house is such
a sweetheart
yeah love that guy so much there's no
reason I just do that show there's not
you know I used to go there and do sets
and it's this is why I had to go back to
the store because it was I could walk on
there on the stage like I just read a
magazine and talk about it those people
were started for Tommy's or somebody had
three jokes didn't you like stars yeah
you know you gotta be pushed when you do
come it's saying you know your training
part there's gotta push it you give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about these sponsors here
don't forget I'm doing Gotham this
weekend sad Friday and Saturday at
midnight if you want to win free tickets
go to Joey Diaz night nectar honey six
calm all right what they tell you to say
twelve hundred hits more vapor
remember yeah it's very tasty long
latter that they have cigars and
cigarettes like flavors for the
cigarettes different levels of nicotine
it's awesome so what's the name of the
company in Haiti cigs doctor sit this is
a very good omen Radek tremendous this
cigar is very good I'm telling you it
tastes good it tastes like a real cigar
when they mailed me this that I've
always used these at the house at night
when I drink coffee when I get back and
doing comic I like a cigar I just didn't
like the drama of going through it so if
you don't like the [ __ ] drama going
through it either
go to hit e-cigs calm and press Joey's
church boom and get 20% off your order
to deliver [ __ ] anywhere knock
yourself out
come to the show on Friday or Saturday
will be they get without samples shaking
hands blowing smoke they're gonna be
they're giving out samples yeah me
undies calm how long have you had those
undies on for [ __ ] three days you
nasty [ __ ] most people have
their underwear for seven years you
filthy [ __ ] Adams isn't that a crazy
you probably you probably got a
Starbucks with that money and on your
head north walking with that horse
breath in the morning especially you
[ __ ] women you don't your [ __ ]
smells like just a mess all night go to
me undies calm right now
damn [ __ ] around me okay for example
I got mine on right now they feel
[ __ ] tremendous I mean Joe we're
talking about how comfortable they are
I they don't let your balls sweat yeah I
had them on for 24 hours around the
shower I want to take away from my
nutsack the next morning there was no
perspiration whatever they have in that
material takes it out of your [ __ ]
nut sack and you [ __ ] you can sling
dick in the morning with confidence okay
so if you can't sling dick in the
morning with confidence what the [ __ ]
are you gonna sling dick confidence go
to me undies write down you look great
tear up the pics and the different
styles I got for men and women go to me
on these calm right now press water Joey
oh [ __ ] and get 20% off and guess what
they delivered the United States [ __ ]
Canada Mars whatever the [ __ ] you need
go to me undies right now but better yet
go mention us and get 20% and they get
free shipping and US and Canada right
new us and they ship their free now
whatever the Jew the Jew brains the free
let me taste
the salt and pepper lima beans from
[ __ ] naturebox has anybody had those
no I had to cry other crunchy stuff
sriracha [ __ ] cashes you have the
jalapeno cashews no then-new oh my god
good very good
delicious don't [ __ ] around a mild
jalapeno it's like a taste you get the
taste of the jalapeno it's not like
stupid spicy where it hurts you to eat
them it's good they also sent me the
Kung Pao pretzels they sent me the
raspberry whatever bars delicious the
baby loves them did you get the dark
cocoa nom nom oh my god I got City
peanut butter Nam loves to I don't the
seen another nom noms did you eat those
oh yeah
done listen I steal this is a
professional step the professional
[ __ ] stone is telling you these
snacks are nutritious delicious you know
got assistant a zero trans fat no
artificial ingredients and they also
have gluten free products go to [ __ ]
naturebox calm and when they press the
box Joey and you're gonna get a free
free free I said it before nothing's
free but Jesus but naturebox [ __ ]
beat me do it you're gonna get a free
box shift the apps so good for you here
you go / Joe stay full say strong do
what you want to do start snacking
smarter go to nature box calm
and get your free slam PO box sampler
box the [ __ ] peanut butter bags yeah
no charge you for shipping guys go to
nature box comments lash Joey
oh yes last Joey and get your free box
sent right to the [ __ ] house don't
[ __ ] around and last but not least my
people on the.com I'm on that [ __ ]
strong bomb right now my knees looking
better
[Music]
yeah I recognize those little scars
now they pulled the stitches out or they
have stitches that dissolve most of the
time they remove the stitches did they
remove your stitches yeah days later
that's it but they [ __ ] when I get on
my hands and knees into a child's pose
oh yeah yes it's scar tissue it's
actually good to feel that pain okay
yeah you have an injury like that you
gotta break it down break down that scar
tissue so we're not [ __ ] around also
it on it they got the new formula for
the T plus 36 percent more strength we
still got out for brain gives you more
focus and more clarity
you still got [ __ ] the caveman coffee
they don't [ __ ] around they got there
they got the new legend about 28 keys
right yeah 62 pounds is a werewolf a
[ __ ] werewolf that weighs 62 pounds
yeah understand me I met a chick that's
[ __ ] was a werewolf [ __ ] a lot of
hair it breathed hot air on me [ __ ] and
last but not least no down a dot-com
aggress Church Church see you see Hur th
get 10% off your first auto blow so Stan
looking on the stay on the program
it works like Dollar Shave Club and all
the other companies we work with they
mail it right the house you have to
start every month gonna calm just [ __ ]
go to Stan get the 10% off the
additional 10% once you mentioned going
also there's my brother's Church also to
my brothers those goomy's your mama's
over at Nelda live.com
they're great guys what's the website
nailed it live.com nailed it live.com
nailed it life.com nailed it life yes
night nai led
I'm LT life.com okay that easy no
drilled it life doc I got the best
taking Debs yeah those guys they go deep
we were driving from allegedly from
Northern California down was a [ __ ]
do they break showed on at the house
with a briefcase remember the other
office he had a sack like Santa Claus
and he reaches in and she's handing
gummy bears out to the children and all
[ __ ] staff
at the Comedy Central taping everybody
was coming pairs are even worse than the
Green Hornet's which are pretty bad of
THC for people don't know regular really
strongly at 70 really strong really
strong like I wouldn't recommend that I
would say take a half or even a quarter
of a 70 is the most [ __ ] up thing guys
we've to achieve the truth yeah we'd all
cheaper choose we'd everything what's
the cheapest you got in there cheaper
true the big ones got 180 little ones
got 70 and the gummy the Green Hornet
got 70 so think of that I'm with 70s in
fact like tic tacs
and but you go from that to 240 what is
that folks everything oh this isn't this
is called a so kind brownie they make
cookies and brownies these are three
brownies divided by three it's 200
milligrams in the back it's 66
milligrams of THC each one I just gave
Lee 50 this is this is the one that
kills I mean people's eyes get red they
got a pullover this is ha ha ha there
ain't nothin I can lie to you here the
cheaper shoes are great but they're 180
million I don't know how these people do
it I'd like to test this [ __ ] this takes
you deep and when he goes home until I
was how deep we be when I call you deep
this is deep and I ask the people what's
going on they say they making with the
original butter that they went back to
old school nobody's doing something
doing the butter I love the 250,000,000
man come it's the little cherry ones
I'll [ __ ] gets popped up and put that
I tuned that iPod on on the plane and
take my little computer out now get
[ __ ] wasted wasted on that flight but
there's nothing like these little 60
milligrams I don't know why I don't know
why I didn't like getting high that one
time on the plane to Austin I didn't
like it daddy no it was - I don't get
really nervous when I'm high but I was
paranoid on that flight there's no
reason to be sober a flight ever I just
waste of a flight unless you ever really
hated import book you have to read but
we took it before we got on the plane
and then there's a bus to the plane so I
was flying by are you gonna ask me at
that bus to them all right when you go
to Utah or [ __ ] Austin you got that
[ __ ] bus so once you land
cross-country on the [ __ ] plane then
they drop you all they jump on a bus and
walk back the [ __ ] American airline I
tell you what that was a city a city and
a club that I was really impressed with
was that wise guys in Utah wise guys in
Salt Lake City I don't that is they in a
great [ __ ] Club and that is a great
[ __ ] town
those people were cool as [ __ ] and it
was you had told me that and a bunch of
the guys who told me that but I had my
apprehension so I was like come on it's
Salt Lake City they're all uptight like
that's the Mormon place they are so
[ __ ] sick of the Mormon for me it
wasn't even about killing you know what
it was for me you know when I fell in
love with them my people would pull me
aside and they go thank you
cuz I look at the Malheur for while they
just thank you thank you
nobody comes here thank you yeah that's
it thank you problem looks me in the eye
and does that to me that means the world
to me like thank you bro
thank you for [ __ ] coming here for
some people people I want to come here
then whatever you know I love if there's
a microphone and a [ __ ] brick wall
you know Joe Rogan I'm sick and tired of
people talking about Tommy clubs like
now but our vibe is so beautiful you
know what bro I lost that [ __ ] about ten
years when I walk into a club they're
all of the same and they all sound
understand to me and the sound system
doesn't impress me and the painting on
the mural and the copper Bell nothing
impresses me the laughter impresses me
and why was the more [ __ ] economy club
has now I don't want to go there why
these guys is perfect perfect so it's
got a little green roof yeah I don't
want to see nothin no more stage sponges
I don't want to hear about the oh my god
well the sound you could listen you
don't suck my dick remember that one
time we were in Vegas this guy was
bombing we're like oh my god it's poor
[ __ ] this is terrible and he comes off
stage the first thing you're saying it's
like they couldn't hear him this is
microphone [ __ ] well we were in the back
of the room we're like we [ __ ] heard
you loud and clear the first thing
people say when they bomb is the sounds
they was old away with him right and I
stopped that [ __ ] about 15 years ago
that's when I started growing as a comic
listen forget the sound forget the
lights you a dick
I bet the commie school when I got that
it's black and the microphones broken
and you're up there yelling from the top
of your lungs and that laughing well you
hear what happened a Heffron once he was
in the middle of show and the [ __ ]
power went out and so he lit they had
candles all over the tables he knows one
of those is an improv you know they do
that impressed
he took a [ __ ] candle held it up to
his face and talked really loud
it just kept going just did the [ __ ]
show hold it onto a candle yelling
really loud like projecting like he's a
Shakespearean actor I go how was it goes
killed killed killed it's the best
feeling in the world your voice is the
strongest weapon that you have when you
don't know it well it's also the
audience gets a chance to see something
unique yeah they know that you're forced
into this situation and they love to say
you adapted I'll find you they love that
you adapted they love it
where are you going next my brothers
this weekend I'm in Toronto I'm going
the Sony Centre you fly up Friday and do
the shoulder fly to Vegas on set yeah
that's Saturday morning I'm commentating
on the well I'm on my reconstruction
phase now cuz I just fill my special
mm-hmm so right now it's all about
writing and doing a lot of local spots
like tomorrow night I'm doing comedy
juice and I'm trying to do I'll try one
up doing a ha ha
next week maybe I'm doing like those
kind of gigs
I'm telling along be trippin me on the
800 Wednesday night if I'm home no I'm
not home that night that's it that's
yeah no I can't do that day that's right
I'll do another one yeah I definitely
want to do Long Beach November go yeah
it's really becoming a fun place for me
I wanna do Santa Barbara to Dino there's
a little comedy club up in Santa Barbara
I did American comedy company down in
San Diego
I'm having a good time down in January
yeah I'm not really good time I'm having
a good time doing clubs like I'm doing
um this Sony Center is gonna be like
3,200 people it's a big [ __ ] place in
Canada it's fun too Canadians are so
polite and they're so nice that they
even a big place you can get away with
it but there's something about those
little places man there's something
about the Icehouse like 190 when it's
stuffed with people there's something
about that man that's that's the best
shows like wiseguys what is wiseguys
like 200 years or something yeah I love
those two there was another best man
Comedy Works in Denver like 250 these
[ __ ] people are opening up these
clothes now
hundreds seedsman like we know why
because they trying to they can move
around they they can get the door
I mean yeah they can get the bar rather
you know they'll give people free
tickets tell them you know you have to
buy two drinks as long as they can keep
having places where comics perform one
of the problems with all these big
places is they don't do no [ __ ] open
mics they got to pack that place to keep
it open like it's a big-ass place in
order to make some money they have to
have a lot of [ __ ] people there and
you can't get a lot of [ __ ] people
for an open mic night whereas a place
like like the Comedy Works wouldn't
think about not having an open mic these
people don't think about having one and
that's it's good for us cuz a guy like
you or I could show up in Irvine and do
the big club that they have now they
have like a 600 seat improv and Irvine
or you could go the stand-up live in
Phoenix which is like I go to tempies
though that's a great class I still look
at times small school they offered me
stand-up lon fantastic be spent on
maternity Guy it's a great part of the
town too you know how I am
once I have something that fits yeah
that copper ballon from that [ __ ]
stand-up live yeah I don't want to look
at that [ __ ] yeah no I don't want to
hear that band sing in the back I don't
wanna have somebody singing [ __ ]
black dawn by Led Zeppelin don't do that
don't do that around yeah that [ __ ]
that bar is fun though it's fun no I'm
only goofing on it but I just don't it's
not for me I don't want that I like
comedy when it's dingy yeah like you
know in its rawest form you know the
other day I came up with that video
again I watched it for two minutes the
Richard Pryor with the the menu behind
them oh that's that catch right actually
the old improv yeah one of those was the
improv something might have been the
improv right because catch didn't have
many kind of stage catch had a mirror
and we've had rock or a B C on the
podcast he said that Richard did not
want to shoot that special
he was like I'm a bomb I know I'm going
down there and they had to do the
material on the way down and it turned
out to be a pretty good special you know
we had Redman in here last week and now
we're talking about something that I
gotta ask you about it's amazing when
you look at the iTunes list now even if
you look at [ __ ] health there's a
thousand podcast and for you this
started for us in a little hotel room
when you would sit down after shows and
green rooms and take my go what do you
[ __ ] guys doing oh we're doing a
podcast get the [ __ ] get let's get the
[ __ ] let's go eat something I see a
pissed and this is where it's all gone
can you believe this it didn't hit me it
didn't hit me about the Rogan podcast oh
we would do Larry's thing last Tuesday I
had one inside my soul Ari on stage I go
this all goes back this is all
centralized back to that that podcast
that little you know if you look at
episode 8 of the GRE now it's a [ __ ]
couch with three people sitting on the
[ __ ] couch Eddie Bravo me you know
and look what it's become we're here we
got Charles Bronson on the wall you know
what the [ __ ] how did this happen well
we figured out a way to do our own show
you know I mean we were trying to do it
before my show still trying to get me to
do it well last time we spoke they would
have 14 episodes in three days joke or
music what do you think Tom will do 14
episodes in three days shoot them all at
the same house it's a different idea
right the way they want to do it now
it's gonna be podcast style right well
it's gonna be like a subject like
whatever the subject is where it's
ghosts or whatever talk to an expert
have a man have chosen videos placing
videos pause the videos goof on it well
I don't know if wound up doing it it's
part of me doesn't want to do it I I
really enjoy just doing things to the
Internet I really enjoy working for the
UFC and I really enjoy doing stand-up I
don't want to do anything that I don't
really enjoy and throw it in there just
because we'll see like this pattern of
most amazing when people call me for a
and still sometimes yeah you don't have
to I'm not going down there I'm not
doing I know what I already see the deal
I already see the whole deal I got to do
this and I'm meant to do this and this
mission is to accomplish this goal you
know what for what to put up with this
to put up with I don't even like that
yeah I mean it's also we've already made
so much progress you know doing it your
way
like you figured out a way we all did
through doing these things in the
internet you figured out a way to be
yourself you know I figured out a way to
to just tap in to whatever the [ __ ] you
are and then also examine the way other
people react to you and it sort of makes
you pump up your own game like it makes
you makes you better at podcasting like
the criticisms that you get or the
suggestions that you get or the guest
suggestions like it's an interactive
sort of relationship that you have with
the people that like the show sometimes
good and sometimes bad I mean you're
gonna run into people that are just
super negative you're definitely gonna
run into people that are just mean and
[ __ ] and complaining about everything
you're also gonna run into people that
some good pieces of advice some people
that goof on you because you say [ __ ]
over and over again you might not even
realize you use a certain word over and
over again and they say clown you want
it and now you have to think about it
but that's good that's good that's a
this has made me better all cuz now I'm
liable when you go to Weight Watchers
what they teach me is you gotta write
everything down yeah if I had an apple
this podcast makes me responsible for my
words now not when I yell this
obscenities racist comments [ __ ]
national it makes you a better comment
but it's made me a better comic but it's
also made me a better person because I'm
said like I walk the walk mm-hmm I can't
come up and say why don't do this now I
gotta walk the walk now right I can't
just go on a coke binge and not come in
here and record the podcast ya know I
couldn't do any I couldn't do anything
you know that's completely contrary to a
lot of people's ideas about what a
person who's clean can and can't do so
like you takin those pills when you had
your knee operation and not worrying
about it at all that's like completely
outside the realm of like any of those
12-step programs they would say don't
ever [ __ ] do
you know you don't have responsibility I
mean you don't have the the the ability
to to say no to that stuff that stuff is
more powerful than you don't bring it
into your life and you're like I figured
something out there's a commercial now
for a rehab that says if you are and
their truck you know 80% of people
relapse and they said if you relapse
they'll take you back and do it for free
you know that's nice all that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is [ __ ] and
for me the beating all that [ __ ] never
wanted to go back it's just becoming a
man your manhood should overcome that
and that's you know that's how I was
raised your manhood overcomes all that
[ __ ] just deciding not to be a little
kid anymore
no I thought to be a saboteur and I saw
my stepdad was and he was a killer he
killed people he shot people he did
things but he had this thing that he
would talk to him though you never doing
that ever again because that's how I
work my sister I'm saying like he was
just very and I got it I got out of a
young age I don't eat this no no I just
don't eat it that's it it's done like
that was it right and everything I don't
want to ever shoot a joy karate video
they were fun to do but I did what I did
now I moved on I did cocaine it was fun
while I did it but not one day I made a
decision people don't want to make a
decision people don't want a while I'm
with you on everything with Joe Girardi
you know what I'm saying
it would look weird if I still for the
Gion you should you Joey jiu-jitsu and I
thought about I thought about George
it's a good idea to so bad it doesn't
matter
join karate at least I had a sidekick no
I'm saying I lose that a sidekick love
with George it's a drama beer no no you
you [ __ ] grab a guy and you pull them
into your guard you start working a
clock choke but you lose it the guy gets
the top you [ __ ] can't breathe and
tap out listen do what I say not what I
do
trust me [ __ ] I'm trying to give
you a good technique over here my grip
is bad
I put jacket off my right hand I'm out
of sorts you can come up with a bunch of
ways to make jujitsu hilarious I love it
and it's funny cuz I get going and I'm
grabbing pants now I'm passion and all I
have is a tackle pass that's all I got
thank God for Dave cavalry oh he's like
what I love you're a great guy don't
curse in my gym
don't say [ __ ] there's a family invite
but do me a favor let's work on this
tackle bass you don't love this pull put
your shoulder on there Godzilla can't
get you off it's a good pass it's a
great bet you should get a pass those
legs and then the guy from John Jacques
to have a chubby guy a black bow he came
to vMac on a Sunday for the open man he
pulled me aside to me let me teach us
this isn't nobody's gonna give you this
all right just do this lace panting you
got the guy then I gotta get up once
you're on top but you gotta lose weight
John Jacques will tell you you're
breathing your diaphragm jiu-jitsu
everybody's looking to help you yeah you
know and that's why I told John Evans
here Sunday you know I read web page go
for jiu-jitsu you don't lose weight
you're gonna get self-confidence you're
in jail he's gonna be better but nobody
says and you know is the family you're
looking for
nobody says the Camerata me because I
did martial arts for 30 years and it's a
big difference on a man's
what's on you I've never had that I've
had me hugging here and I'm sweaty yeah
it's very different you go to me Joe